une production du studio sf à l'or
bienvenue aux sans filtre balado le
balado où on parle de ce que l'on veut
avec nos invités
c'est tout je suis pascal hugo caron
quentin avec moins dominique allain des
plantes
bonjour salut tout le monde
le pack est encore une fois par écolo
fitness économique nes c'est mon james
est 11e
on a fait tirer un abonnement platine
blu quelques semaines oui oui moi aussi
je vais avec la montagne de gagner un
abonnement platine fait que la gagne et
que nous avons rejoint écolo finesse et
78e au québec avec la passe platine que
annick la montagne au gagner vous pouvez
aller dans tous les james au québec vous
avez accès à des cours de groupe sur
écran géant vous avez accès à des
trainings 30 minutes si vous êtes
pressés vous avez accès à un programme
d'entraînement selon vos besoins c'est
un jam ultra sens super bien équipée
sans jugement donc allez voir dans la
description de du podcast d'avoir plus
d'informations sur ecolo fitness merci
la gagne deco finesse pour cette
collaboration dans le dernier épisode où
il y ait deux un commentaire aujourd'hui
qu'au quitte l'entreprise de mai à
cuisiner vous choisissez vos plus vous
recevez des boîtes par la poste avec
tous les ingrédients frais tous les ce
que ça prend pour cuisiner d excellente
recette à chaque semaine le choix des
quatorze délicieuse recette vous
permettre de premières mois résultat
votre gaspillage alimentaire parce que
vous avez exactement les quantités
exactes pour faire des recettes bien
proportionné vous avez
résulat la charge mentale de caisse que
je veux cuisiner cette semaine qui
seront mangés le vous choisissez sur
tout ce que vous avez besoin d'aller
chercher d'ingrédients nul pas tout et
le c'est important de cuisiner à la
maison c'est important de bien manger
cocquyt vous encourager vous vous aider
à avoir de bonnes habitudes de vie
les recettes sont testés par des
nutritionnistes et par des chefs coq est
une entreprise
nous voyons des options vg vendredi bien
vendredi
peu importe ça vous regarde pas la
journée mais un petit coupon les
rencontres jesse est moins pour ma
copine et moi en fait pour vegan mais
pas là pour des recettes végétalienne
possible avec cook it puis si vous vous
inquiétez du gaspillage déplacez vous
pouvez ramener tous eu un coût qu'il
réutilise tous les sacs
on a un code promo ouais on a que
promouvoir la description des vidéos qui
est sans fil du temps d'avoir 50 % de
rabais sur les deux premières boîtes
coquette que vous avez commandé n'est ce
pas merveilleux merci la gagne de
coquettes piscine on s'est tenu cette
semaine on a reçu lucie rayons mais qui
influencent instagram et youtube buzz
une personne avait personnalité
attachante pétillante personne aussi une
femme d'affaires oui c'est surtout sur
fond d'affaires une femme très
travaillante aussi très très jeune
beaucoup plus jeunes que nous dans des
grands parents commencent à la 20 ans à
la double less in flames et gold rush
gagne et elle va l'université a fait des
vidéos youtube fait son propre montage
qui est excellent dans un fil twitter
d'affaires une grande travaillante comme
je le dis plutôt ou si une personne
super sympa c'est que super je pense pas
drôle qu'on a adoré rencontrer connu une
superbe la conversation j'espère que
vous allez aimer autant qu'il dit ouais
c'était une confrontation ultra
intéressante c'est vraiment une personne
qui je pense que le définitif c'est chop
chop sur tout ce qui est fait puis puis
c'était vraiment super cool dit par les
laisser dans les commentaires qu'est ce
que vous pensez de la conversation
like et partager écouter un grand nombre
ça nous fait toujours extrêmement
plaisir puis on vous aime bien mais vous
les uns les autres aussi l'importance
beaucoup d'affect fait beaucoup de
vagues dans le monde dans lequel on vit
profitez en pour vous aimez puis vous
allez vous faire rendre la pareille donc
sans plus attendre bomba de khost merci
d'être ici avec nous si on commence à
voir et autres habits suis semble être
la personne la plus occupée en ce moment
que je suis sur les intervenants
semblent avoir un million d'ha fort qui
se passe dans ma vie en ce moment en
plus de fin de session qui s'en vient
comment tu vis comme officiel aiu
holdings à beinheim ans parce que moi
j'ai toujours des personnes que jean
plus j'ai des projets dans ma vie le
mieux je me porte donc toujours ouais
j'ai pas toujours été comme ça comme des
dit que chaque seconde à j'ai commencé à
vraiment guéri bob dans paint activité
je faisais du curry d une compétitive de
haut niveau ouais ouais
avant que je sois sur les charlotte
bande de cheerleading
ouais ouais second la compétition ça
c'est parce que là c'est vraiment états
une équipe
mal adéquate en équipe à windy r'n'b a
effectué sept ali au championnat
semences et quinson ça c'était en 2005
et non moi j'ai garé celle mon idée
préconçue le ton nom comme 12 ans qui
m'aident à partir du second âge et
comment ces ajustements face à ce genre
d'activités je dois aussi j'ai joué du
piano vraiment longtemps j'y joue encore
jusqu'à logique accès à mon piano j'ai
joué pendant comme 12 ans aussi fixé
comme près de trucs qui m'ont forcé à
être disciplinés très jeune puis mes
parents aussi si ces deux personnes qui
ont sonné pillon grandi dans l'extrême
pauvreté puis ont vraiment travaillé
fort pour ce qu'ils ont puis c'est
vraiment comme des varois qui m'ont
transmises par rapidement le quai moi et
mon frère justement de ce nouveau logo
on travaille tous tant pis on est ultra
discipliné tout fait qu'énoncer au cube
d'eau grandi moi personnellement j'ai
grandi je connais pas ce que mon cousin
matin il y habite avec un kart et si on
est les soins saint-sulpice à saint
sulpice al-fadl à saint sulpice et we
saw tu vois ça c'est un souvenir que j
pour muscler noël et noël sont plus là
même à libourne les familles de la cité
the way mais pas que c'est que depuis
que mes parents sont séparés en fait
parce que comme la lino elles perdent
c'est comme tu dis lui un peu de noël
mais tu vois cette année ça a parfois
qu'ils ont fait à noël chez nous juste
la famille petite famille pas des coudes
si oui c'est comme de ces changements
génération je prenais avez-vous des
grosses familles quand même moins mais
c'est quand même mais c'est ça la force
et y mettant le moi depuis que je me
rappelle on passe à autre chose qu'on
demande
mais d'aussi longtemps que je me
rappelle il y avait juste mon grand père
tu mets ton mon grand père et ma grand
mère il n'y avait pas leurs frères fait
inévitablement il ya un moment dans la
vie où est-ce que tu arrêtes de fêter
noël avec tes frères des soeurs puis
juste dans les andes rieuse ta
descendance ça réussit mal fou à ce que
le team est honteux non elles sont
grands pas c'est fragile les fils a été
petit cousin l'heure c'est juste en
vidéo 30 ans partenaires ça devient
vraiment organiser une aussi grosse
réunion familiale fait qu'effectivement
des parents ont grandi dans la pauvreté
extrême
quant aux grands dit c'était dans quel
milieu social en qualifiant social
dépendantes est ressorti de ce mois ci
s'agit vraiment un véhicule et le
contraire
dans le fond c'est ma maman récupère
puis mon père québécois fait que ma mère
était qu'elle grandisse et aide en temps
du communisme a qui veulent fait que
manquent de nourriture et tout ce qui
s'était vraiment la grande île lab est
parti qu'ils allaient rencontrer mon
père en fait vous en vain contre il a
beau accuser mon petit malade c'est vrai
c'est comme une histoire même du saumon
pas d'enfants mais oui oui mais la tête
toute mon attention c'est d'enfants mon
père y est toujours aimé ce genre les
bateaux est tout sauf à clé dès que plus
à ce genre l'une des proches ont aussi
affecté comme de s'acheter un bateau
quand il était chez nous au québec et
tous ceux qui commençaient plus c'est
que ce faux faites le dans cette période
là il y avait un bateau qui était comme
dans gens à miami puis tout ça fait que
les airs en 91 92 quand quelques bugs ou
va ses portes aux touristes parce qu'il
avance est complètement fermé mon père
il ya décidé d'y aller comme hbo vient
d'ouvrir un nouveau bond à park vient
d'ouvrir ses carnets du bo vient
d'ouvrir des bars clubs et c'est assez
fou fait comme il lui tarde vie là-bas
en bateau puis comme des marines à la
veille avait aucun touriste ne s'était
pas bien aidé seul tour et c'est tout
mais lui adresser la voiture est tombée
en amour avec s est rendu à la havane
ouais ça devait être hot avant le
tourisme quand même un challenge autres
les en février métier là avance quand
même pas comme mettons varadero
maintenant nova comme je trouve qu'on a
quand même vu vu c'était quoi
si les cubes os x qui parce que c'est
comme au retour un peu comme les vieux
char les buildings les vieux tout
puis comme il ya vraiment une grande
mèche été isolés pendant longtemps
longtemps longtemps ce qui fait que
c'est comme au retour
tarif 3 80 ans tu es comme mai
non c'est ça qui est lui vraiment tombe
en amour avec cet endroit donc il
commence à y aller comme à chaque fois
qu'ils pouvaient avec le bateau et
toupie ma mère à ce moment là l'enfant
en étudie pour devenir médecin dans
l'armée fait que d'enfoncer c'était à la
vente
et puis un dimanche sa mère donc ma
grand-mère était comme hospitalisation à
l'heure donc le yen à y prendre une
petite marche du dimanche vous seul et
puis tous sont passés près de la marine
puis le mon père était le puits en somme
son lob seulement parce que ma mère à la
base et bruno dubout mois puis à ce
moment là se teignant les cheveux en
blond chiasme hôtel ivoire de contact
bleus qui c'est la femme de ma vie c'est
comme directement clip c'est fou parce
qu'elles sont mal à mon pari
baragouinait il parlait à peine
l'espagnol fois qu'ils sont rennais à
peine mais comme c'était suffisant pour
puis après ça ça s'est passé très
rapidement donc pas avec alors je sais
pas que mon père à ce moment là il y
avait des arbres 50
alors ouais mon père c'est quelque chose
que j'ai jamais parlé publiquement
tutoie la barre du whisky ouais pas si
j'en parle de plus en plus mais j'ai
jamais dit l'ange de mon pas mal
nécessaire mais non 6 avec mon père
s'essayer icom plus enregistrés comme
peu sa différence d'âge alma - puis dans
deux sociétés nord-américaines c'est
quelque chose qui campe aussi pas bien
perçu sur la relation
même moi personnellement je l'avais pas
senti que je le savais pas jusqu'à temps
que j'ai revu ou secondaires et genres
tenté mon enfance puis tous est pour moi
ça c'est pas normal que c'était à ma
famille que dans le personnage maya cuba
aussi c'est que c'est comme ça depuis
c'est vraiment quelque chose qui comme
ce pas normal quand tu veux dans les
pays en lice entre amis depuis deux ans
ces jours-ci par mois mais quand tu
arrives ici tu vois un homme plongé avec
une femme plus jeune jean les gens
n'aiment pas rapidement du mois ci c'est
quelque chose que j'avais pris comme
épine on s'est moqué de tout tes amis
leur part avaient 40 plutôt temps par y
avait 65 m way motel mes amis me
paraissent l'appareil avait genre télé
de 40,1 mais tant pis
une hôtesse faire en bonne santé tous
ont un pied et puis moi en vieillissant
système on l'a senti mon passé mieux se
dégrader rapidement
ok quand on était jeunes solistes pas
bien puis comme d'un coup j'ai fait que
c'est un attachement à voir cubes au
dessus comme si c'était un peu tard ma
patrie un sens où nos portes
bien sûr que oui je reste encore
incertain certain attachement
mais pour moi c'est depuis que d'enfants
comme ma famille après midi à la cub et
qui est ma tante et ma grand-mère ont
immigré aussi au canada fac depuis que
eux ont immigré au canada comme témoin
c'est sûr qu'il avait pu vraiment
content ni la belote parce que s'ils
savent pas d'aller là bas ça encourage
le gouvernement à qui encore peu comme
si pas bon en ce moment 5e 8 mhz et est
allé quand même oui je suis allé mais
comme l'a dit à la fois qu'il fallait
pour vous ma famille je dois bourges en
huit ans que j'apprécie je suis retourné
mais comme avec des amis jean à varadero
fact vraiment pas pour la famille mais
cette année mon frei est allé l'on
revoit un service basé comme disent
inquiets on les a pas vus mais il y
avait peu vu billets jusqu'à une partie
d'eux seuls pigeons il l'aurait dit
qu'il s'en venait puis quand même parce
qu'on ne trouvait contact parfait mais
c'est vraiment une particule éloigné de
la famille à cuba comme retrouver nos
facebook puis comme aline dont écrit
plier des gens en oeuvre nous volent
tout fait que les flamands simon fra
italie on ne dise pas vivre chiites ou
l'est y étaient restés les gens un mois
qui est investi la famille frank et moi
je pense que j'aimerais c'est français
est à l'image déjà que jamais
rencontrées pour la plupart y en a
beaucoup que oui que j'ai rencontré
justement quand j'étais jeune j'étais en
vain mais même ça fait plaisir ça fait
comme douce très gentille légende les
gens disent échanges puis juste
maintenant mon frère italie cette année
piété commode ce rappel de notre cuisine
quelques pour moi est un tout et il
disait jean ben men est enfin le genre
est ce pas jean le cam sa raison
effectivement une autre réalité au 6 mai
je me sens quand même prête à jean
alerté la famille ces gens comme vous
que trouver ces parcelles un peu mon
bagage
est ce que tu vas te parler en espagnol
on parle toujours de pagnol ouais mais
c'est vrai c'est moi j'adore ce jour en
espagne heures et moi je réponds
français car quand tu lis parle au
téléphone ne suis pas en français tout
tu parle en français les locales en
espagne qui s'effectue ça fait en sorte
que quand j'arrive au palace en espagne
appauvri est comme des fois je lui dis
mon pigeon j'ai un petit accent pitou
alliez sauter quand même pas mal plus
fluide que beaucoup de manques
ok sur les attentats c'est ok je sais
même pas nos caisses ou sinon fake
revenons en prenant après c'est
secondaire
quand la culture comment ça tu commences
à faire j'imagine du cheerleading
secondaire auprès d'un jury créativement
mais j'avais commencé mes chats veaux
seconde hop le salage sont secondaires
incluent y avait une équipe de
cheerleading à mon école je l'aï dit tu
as dit que ces gens se serrent la main
devrait être calme en poche 10 genre ça
on n'était vraiment pas une bonne équipe
comme ça le tuning amont et consomme on
en a existé une année j'en avais aucune
technique c'est mauvais puis même ans
que de commencer le genre on était on
était quand même aller à une compétition
en plus c'est un maillot c'est tellement
gênant on est à une compétition qu'on
était tellement poche qu'on ait le même
temps une chorégraphie au complet de
gens on faisait comme minutes de
chorégraphie se remettant deux minutes
trente dont dix comme couper la musique
en tout cas c'est vraiment un peu jean
marie v vais pas rester
mais entre de voir tout ce monde où on
allait en compétition devront être les
hôtes et qui était vraiment bonne
justement j'avais vu dans une
compétition à windy vu comme leur équipe
qui était comme au niveau du championnat
du monde cette année le pilot j'y voyais
fauchage en règle comme ça je sais ce
que je veux faire un jour être comme ça
que les tic au suivi je vais aller faire
les listes royal comme qui j'ai fait un
quartier où si j'enregistre ou en fait
comme ni camp d'entraînement précieux
mam n'a rien du tout parce qu'elle veut
j'ai commencé ipar tort comme
habituellement si ses responsables comme
la comme la gymnastique et tout tu veux
commencer ce jeune parce qu'ils
apprécient comme clash at love c'est la
souplesse quand quand vidéo est élevé
plus la notion comme du risque va comme
nous mettons si tu veux faire un back
flip sur place [ __ ] j'en fais de ta
vie puisque comme 15 ans c'est plus
simple de ce moment parce que tu sais
c'était d'ailleurs et ça fait mal
c'était très exactement 5 et 6 la fac
les après ça ça m'a lâché j'ai commencé
au compétitif avec marine dit conquis je
pense m'en être deux élevages en 13 14
ans puis le mon objectif à chaque année
ce tekken d'augmenter de haut niveau aux
tubes et ses clients cinq niveaux marc
fouilland le 6 mai comme le le cinquième
essai celui où est ce que tout le monde
veut compétitionner au champion du monde
pour ça et tout ça que j'ai déjà
commencé à prêcher niveaux niveaux 1 et
2 c'est toujours deux équipes pour
m'entraîner de l'extérieur un peu plus
intense et to peer et ça ça devient
l'année niveau du rythme toujours en
augmentant c'est vraiment ce que j'aurai
deux pour faire deux fois pelouse
d'entraînement
ouais c'est ça je ce qu'il fallait que
moi puis aussi parce qu'il me classer à
chaque fois que je faisais les croyances
la fac cécile parce qu'on les regarde
ton niveau plus une semaine après ben 10
dans quelle équipe n'a été prise
j'ai en moi me prenait tout le temps à
l'équipe thema ton la plus proche mais
ton niveau 1 dit le mois chacun des noms
comme je peux je peux beaucoup et je
peux vous voyez que je capable jamais
inquiété comme acquis mais doit rester
dans cet acte et où des buts était celle
qui khaled à oreille plutôt fini dans le
niveau 5 a débuté à tellement jeta
tellement poche en règle n'a racheté en
niveau 1 juste pour vous donner une idée
c'est moi j'avais 14 ans puis les autres
filles
dans mon équipe qui était dans ce niveau
là avaient tous à peu près 8 9 ans et
quand même je faisais c'est ce que font
chaque année 45 les pompiers
et puis moi ça m'a quand même puis à ce
moment les dérivés signifie que j'ai
découvert sur les réseaux sociaux qui
s'appelle gaby bloqué à sa mort et ces
gens instagram qu'il irait recommencer
puis avec le monde du reading a commis
elle est vraiment une bien encore à ce
jour il vraiment connu une bulle du
cheerleading sourire et sociaux qui est
un genre vraiment une grosse communauté
par rapport à ça
puis elle s'était comme cc c'est
vraiment incroyable était vraiment super
flexible mais comme ça après sa jambe
cash pencher de même qu'il aime moi je
tombais sur ses vidéos et ses photos
parce que ces quatre fois le genou alors
c est l enfant en fait je m'en
rappellerai que mon stack wells which is
et qu'elle avait mis une vidéo sur
youtube de comment classer tir et puis
comment il avait fait pour devenir
flexible puis à montrer un peu le 10 nov
je fais comme qui le force à chaque jour
je me souviens face à chaque jour une
trophée flexible mais elle est justement
à l'aller au champion du monde mais moi
ce genre qui fait face à plus touffu
mon but c'était vraiment des argos et -5
que madonna années de ce mois ci soit
mon ami que je fais gens que je
compétitionne au champion ou puis c'est
bien forcée de faire mon travail des
personnels
ça m'a beaucoup appris basse et sur le
support d'autres conditions la fête du
port du coup le niveau c'est la chose
qui quittent enseigne le plus la rigueur
puis on ne serait pas même personne s'en
sortent ça t'apprend tellement de leçon
de vie de discipline de travail ccsa sa
forme d'aidé bon des blues - le sport
vous avez commencé
moi j'ai commencé à 5 5 puis perdre si
c'est devenu plus sérieux c'est sûr
apprécié opprimant quand je rentrais
quand j'arrive à québec en 4e année
place esparre études fictive du fait que
seules 15 mai
c'est au début à saint cast et une fois
semaine samedi soit deux fois ce
dimanche après ce geste et le soir après
l'école 3 soit qu'elles soient prêts ce
sport études cinq jours après son
secondaire si samedi matin
que d'agressivité vraiment 8,8
entraînements toutes les après midi puis
trois matins à 6 ans nancy jeudi vendus
mardi jeudi samedi matin les centres
voici là et qu'on ait la piscine
maintenant j'ai deux ans on allait à
l'école au retour d'un engin autres deux
ans après à nos profs le des fois des
fois on arrivait je me rappelle quand il
s'appelait le prof d'histoire comment
rosa rosa rappelle américaine tacc je
sortais c'était au second marché dans
son larcin au cap les cours d'histoire
au début on sort l'entraînement puis je
me mets à planter des clous mais je
m'assois la rance qui secoue relais
m'intéressait juste assez en avant plus
j'ai pas dormi
le jeune entraîneur le plan des clous
qu'un se clamer je relève la joie qui me
regardait faire seul
comment découragea démoralisant sur la
tête pour un professeur de voir ton
élèves qui est assis le qui fait juste
littéralement sans laure mais des fois
tu des fois tu faisais suis réveillé par
le prof
et on peut dire que ces vacances à
l'habilité dans l'école sortie de la
piscine on a les genres déjeuner vite
vite comme à l'école au club des petits
déjeuners par en terre neuve encore les
cheveux mouillés on rentrait dans on
sentait le chlore genre de la classe
déclare on avait les cheveux blonds gens
quand même en détruisant tout brûlé par
lui que je
par la piscine seulement des photos du
monde 14 secondes à celle annoncée
j'ai logé par quatre arbitres et les ti
cats sur tomb latapie des photos
facebook le relais des belles photos
mais c'est sûr que oui moi y'en a qui
sont pas très vegan sur mon facebook les
ménages s'est pas fait mais là je me
suis dit j'ai déjà mangé de la viande
était pareil suède est satisfait d'être
aussi a dû répliquer par un score non
mais maintenant si vous êtes l'un des
clubs de la ville et pendant je faisais
chez mon montestruc principal que je
sais le piano et c'est là qu'elle lui
pratique il faut longtemps puis michael
fincke the fucking genre de type 7
cameron cole tu vois tu la vois tous ces
bons avec fake là on sort et en sorte
secondaire qui on est et en quelle année
le toit de 20/20 au bac et fait que le
ça fait trois ans que j'ai l'impression
que c'est plus long que ça
ouais ben oui mais en même temps parce
que le cégep a tout passé comme un
claquement de deux ans moi j'allais à
sainte-anne je sais pas si vous
connaissez j'aime mais comme il mange
c'est à la chine depuis meilleur si je
venais de manger tellement comme trip
est là bas sont tellement comme open moi
c'est vraiment c'est aussi jeune que
georgi j'ai commencé un peu comme sur
les réseaux que j'ai commencé à publier
sur youtube et tout un stade rempli tout
ce pilot j'ai commencé à voir comme des
contreparties travail par rapport de ce
puits des opportunités aussi puis
n'importe quel établissement scolaire
normal vaut pas légitimité sur
exactement à murray tout simplement dit
des gens arrêtent denise et piquante et
confronte aux 6-12 veut alors que haïti
je leur ai expliqué puis on était
tellement réceptifs ils m'ont ils ont
décidé de m'encourager à 100% donc moi
je n'en priante de sport et aurélie tu
parce qu'elle vu que jeu d'enfant avec
une agence et connaissez c'est comme ça
que ça faisait partie du projet du tout
coller me permettait de m'absenter de
l'école qui est des examens si
nécessaire à ce camp que j'avais du
travail des opportunités to fakie fous
pareils faisait conciliation le avec le
web
a white tellement parce qu'elle est
appréciée et n en font moins l'effet de
mondeville dans la boxe est apte avait
commencé à attaquer sur les réseaux
qu'un au secondaire un petit peu où vous
pleuré quand j'étais au secondaire avec
le tueur mais ton jeu prennent souvent
des photos comme elle aux compétitions
du leading et tous ceux qui le coach des
excuses expliqué tantôt comme des tueurs
fait que j'ai commencé à avoir une
communauté dans ce milieu un fake c'est
un peu ce qui m'a fait commencer je
dirais puis après à l'été entre mon
format 5 puis mon cégep je suis allé
faire un voyage d'un mois qu'elle
fournit avec ma mère à micola qui tous
qui on était partis juste les deux
pouvoir prétendre d'anglais qui
s'appelle ef cadrage hégire travailler
avec eux a pris quelqu'un de spécial on
en est ce qui est la vie fonctionne de
façon mystérieuse pi c'est à ce moment
là j'ai comment j'en prenais plein une
photo puis tout s'est fait comme le
genre j'ai commencé à prendre des photos
de ses voyages et to see
moi j'aime bien plus marcher mais d'en
bas mais plus tellement c'est encore
relatifs à béton à ce moment là je
pensais que j'avais genre je vais pas en
tant qu' cinq et dix mille abonnés de
quelque chose comme ça que tu es moment
où est-ce que ça a fait un boom oussedik
tout inconstant puis c'est quand même
été assez constant et égal dans le sens
quitté j'avais commencé vraiment sur mon
instagram puis le commandement instagram
comme dirt 2 sec et des pages république
il faut tout ça ça fait plus de deux ans
c'était avant même qu'elle ait une
seconde stories existe rapid e set mais
c'est pas pour moi je comme cet effet un
big bio parce que je publiais juste sur
instagram juste des photos puis comme
juste des caps chaîne en anglais donc ok
moi mais maintenant que je parle plus en
france est factice tas de gens vraiment
vraiment une image que je m'écris comme
deux mois sur les réseaux là c'était
aussi comme superficielle du tout le
hockey parce qu'il est plutôt tu ne
connais que au regard des ressources
c'était il ya une déconnexion la bri
woippy le passage sont définitivement
mais pas seulement le ski moi j'ai bien
fait et pas d'autres il n'y a pas
vraiment d'autre choix comme tu es même
si cesc veut justement souhaite toi tu
publies une belle photo peut-être un cap
shaw média quel point tu peux être toi
avec ces deux médias non méthylé les
faits décrits dans une langue qu'ils
parlent alors que ta langue guide paru
au jour le jour
déjà le ya quelque chose le pit et ça
n'est pas aussi quel genre de dewitt
faisait miroiter ou refléter aussi à ce
moment là c'est surtout parce que jean
moi je faisais ce que je pensais qu'ils
étaient en fait tu as puis ça c'est
juste que c'est en regardant mon contenu
dans ce sens le comme ça le fait pas
vraiment une
ma personnalité tout court de vue
médical et que je pense parler aussi
puis le si je me rappelle quand j'ai
voulu justement commencé youtube il est
tellement mettez qui avait une seconde
crise qui commençait pour ses frais une
pression de gens mais qui met les gens
vont m'entendre parler pauvres est-ce
que
les gens comme qui me suivent qui
pensent que je parle anglais le jeu par
français est ce qu'elle est c'est bon on
s'en fout d'eux mêmes sur youtube ces
gens polis gentils dans le vide ne sais
pas quoi
à quoi ça va comment ça va sortir autant
aucune de ces animaux ma première vidéo
every c'est une vidéo du championnat du
monde et tu le dit justement de
séquences vidéo gens voyagent le factice
tech sommes pas vraiment ma personnalité
c'était aux championnats du monde dont
mais un ferry à ça c'est vraiment moi ce
qui m'a donné envie de commencer c'était
d'immortaliser les expériences comme
vraiment incroyable que je vivais qui à
ce moment le le championnat je me dis ah
yoye je vis maintenant faut bien se
souvenir de ce prêt si j'avais commencé
à face a graduellement premier voyage
message prend une petite vidéo pile
après ce jeu c'est bon qu'il faut
rejoindre ma personnalité je parle et
puis c'est là que j'ai commencé sur
youtube puis on dirait que le ca pour
continuer avec mon parcours importe il
est gratuit de mon sujet et puis après
ça ça fait un an j'ai commencé au hec à
temps plein ça c'est vraiment l'heure on
peut on peut montrer les deux exemples
établissements scolaires donc sainte
anne qui était fou le réceptif
compréhension parce que je à ce que je
faisais
comparativement ou à chécy qui comme ils
voulaient 0 m'écouter m françois que
beaucoup de programmes universitaires
qui font qu'avec le le web c'est surtout
qu'elle souhaitait aussi nouveau mais
compris que se retire pour une
génération t on s'entend que les gens
qui administre séolis man 2 ils
comprennent pas ils connaissent pas
c'est parce qu'ils ne peuvent - c'est
peuvent pas comprendre la réalité où que
ce soit même cela explique peut-être
passer un petit pied ou sur la tête tu
étais à quoi je sais et eu des problèmes
je voyais en administration des affaires
contrefaçon marketing fait que j'avais
fait maintenant font ma prononciation la
boîte en plein été comme cinq courts
puis avec mon mon travail comme l'année
dernière et je suis vraiment là j'ai
commencé à faire un revenu depuis que ce
soit vraiment comment un emploi comme
stable puis
si c'était vraiment difficile de
concilier les deux j'avais si leur
parler pour leur expliquer c'est juste
de prendre un cours en moins j'espère
que comme cette course est vraiment pas
une grosse licence clean
c'est vraiment une non catégorique
c'était uniquement réservées pour les
carabins et l'entv or ils étaient tous
fait anti keuf à grim moi j'ai pu faire
ce que je voulais par contre universal
rouge et or
j'aurais pu prendre un coup ham en fêtes
prenait 3 minimum le même si j'aurais pu
prendre trois courbit date des faits qui
fait fait regarder concilier sûr c'est
celle-là ce à sa fin voyons à ce moment
là on dirait que tu as raison je repense
amis dans les années de vip cette
période c'était vraiment rohff
mentalement à cause de la charge de
travail que j'avais aussi c'était le
moment que sa marque et un an depuis le
décès de mon père écoutait beaucoup a en
même temps que je me suis dit il faut
que vraiment que je change de camp est
bien en ce moment ça marche peu puis
parce que tu si je veux continuer mes
études mais je me suis aussi mon travail
il ya quelque chose que je dois faire il
faut soi mais un moyen de concilier deux
facs
ce que j'ai trouvé c'est de poursuivre
mes études universitaires en ligne avec
la téluq puis au début c'était vraiment
une entente avec le hc avec l'achat si
donc il me permettait de prendre des
cours en ligne puis de revenus ou h et
éventuellement propre démon blond mon
bac hec tous nos sous la condition
enfants que je fasse juste une majorité
des courses sur le campus le fait qu'ils
mettront 50 % les coûts mais là
maintenant que j'ai commencé en ligne
comme ça veut juste tellement mieux pour
moi j'ai des meilleures notes jeu plus
productive à chaque jour j'apprends
mieux j'assimile amateurs fakty je me
dis que c'est vraiment aux études comme
au bout de ligne pour moi en ce moment
pourquoi je le déplore t il fait pour
l'apprentissage puisque pour le papier
mais si ça je sois fort besoin de papier
mais si c'est parce que pour moi
maintenant niveau travail et je sais que
les gens qui vont h essais ils font pour
avoir l'été comme hec bakala beaupuy
tout passer sa part et bip c'est vrai ça
balance
pour se faire embaucher peut avoir un
bon emploi mais j'avais déjà mon travail
comme tout jeu 10 août ici pour aider à
mieux gérer tes propos c'est exactement
ouais vraiment comme des apprentissages
que je peux et pis ça marchera mieux
lotis maintenant j'ai suivi mon cours de
comptabilité puis le comité en ce moment
à chaque jour je dois en faire la
comptabilité pour but d' entreprise
personnellement et too fake
s'il est bon je suis à vous détendre les
coûts des outils que probablement que
j'aurais que je pourrais très bien
utilisée en ce moment oui plus que
jamais dans ma vie
l'éducation c'est jamais perdu ça fait
plus là tu dis que ça faisait un an sur
mon blog tu avais que tu gagnes et que
tu as un emploi à temps plein dans son
look et un revenu fixe
puis c'était quoi justement poste à quoi
ton revenu c'est quoi qui produit est
ton ton revenu statut les visionnements
sur youtube c'était dessus parce que ce
sont certains que s'est pas fait c'est
quoi ces les collaborations sur
instagram des collaborations avec avec
les marques
c'est fou parce que quand il peut dans
ce monde là où quelque peu ça aurait pas
là dedans comme les gens savent pas bien
mais c'est quoi la valeur de tout ceci
le combi émettons limare qui
investissent là dedans c'est fou parce
que l'élément 3,2 entrées de rediriger
leurs immenses budget qui mettait dans
les médias traditionnels et m online
dans le marketing d'influencé tout sauf
agressé comme c est quand même très
prospère puis les gens ils s'attendent
pas vraiment ça parlons-en jamais parce
que parce que c'est sûr que l'on voulait
aborder sa victoire avec fondée dans le
fond et influences way qui est sous
influence
les deux font des influences ça a
commencé quand puis quel est le
raisonnement derrière
web depuis le début ça m'intéresse
vraiment beaucoup parce que c'est ça les
occupe une place que qui était
nécessaire france dans le paysage du
marketing web fait que sékou keïta qui
t'a amené à créer ce bel enfant tout a
commencé
ça fait un an et demi d'enfants quand
j'ai rencontré cindy nicolaï qui est ma
partenaire dans in fine ce que je gagne
aussi la deuxième entreprise puis mais
maintenant dans une phase où on est
rendu trois partenariats aussi alexandre
crosby après mais c'est ça fait un
moment que j'ai rencontré cindy qui
était au moment ça faisait comme deux
mois j'avais commencé ma chaîne youtube
et demain moment marc hein parce qu'on
s'est rencontrés ou youtube ce pays ce
qu'est d'enfants ça c'est youtube qui se
déplace au travers le monde qui font des
petits événements dans certaines villes
qui ont peu lois propres youtube space
c'était vraiment particulier parce que
quand même ils viennent d'être est
rarement montréal ils viennent une fosse
où comme je suis pas quatre ans quelque
chose comme ce jeu moi ce moment et je
me suis et comment c'est sur youtube que
j'avais pas accès à genre ou aux
journées de l'événement pour rester des
nombres d'abonnés gentil travaux minimum
dix mille abonnés ou elle veut pas ça
moi j'en avais jean dominante que j'ai
rencontré sin au 5 à 7 il y avait là bas
puis avec homme plein de créateurs à
plein de gens comme un peu les agences
puis tous des gens qui travaillent dans
minuit pile on s'est rencontrés là-bas
puis comme on parlait pour l'été comme à
yopougon s'est pas rencontrés avant mes
30 et pourquoi terry dans ce cas là
c'est mutuellement des réseaux mais
comme on avait eu aucun genre
d'événement propice pour se rencontrer
puis on s'était dit sereine risque de
faire de quoi pour contenir la
communauté de créateurs ou puis côté des
gens qui sont dans ce milieu le fait que
le une semaine plus tard à m'appelle
pierre me dis oh j'ai un ami qui habite
à san diego que comme c'est un
businessman et où il veut que je viens
de là bas pour donner pour l'aider pour
ses réseaux sociaux je suis né avec moi
jusqu'au bout j'ai toujours des
rencontres et c'est ce que c'est drôle
on se dit que là on s'en va là bug bien
ça veut dans son ensemble et je
rencontre john key legault qui habite à
san diego
gorges en full business et toupie comme
t on qu'on s'est un peu pour cyril ce
sous de sa compagnie puis nous dit
acquis mais comme pourquoi vous vous
mettez pas de l'argent derrière ce que
vous faites gentil ndt et vous savez que
les gens seraient prêtes à payer pour
les cons c'est sûr que vous me donnez en
ce moment qui s'écoule toujours gratuit
à san diego
cfa clicquot mais qui battait quoi
demain on va les présenter une
conférence ici à san diego
confer était le cadeau que me suis pas
fatigué et on se met à monter tout le
contenu d'une conférence qui sera
orienté jean pauly gens plus jeunes
débutants les entrepreneurs entreprises
qui veulent commencer puis pour leur
montrer comme un genre était vraiment
les basics puis réseaux sociaux et
baisers des réseaux sociaux mobiles est
fan de dun conférence la maintenance
dans le petit café que l'on a fait de la
promotion de l'événement sur carte
shopping fatigué quand même genre 12
personnes saison pourrie qui on te payer
genre je pense à 5 de rome comme diderot
qui chauffe un peu puis on a fait un
document qui toujours été comme plus
rapide
c'est la première conférence est vrai
qu'on a donnée pile après ces dates à
partir de là on y revient à montréal
pilon 6e qui comme voigt faut qu'on le
fasse pour vrai il ya une demande des
gens qui veulent se faire quelques mois
et on a fait le premier inn florence que
c'était 2-2 journée
avec la même conférence que moi ici nous
dit on a présenté ses conférences
causeries comme trois ans à peu près il
y avait des partis et où c'était
vraiment pour les gens qui voulaient
devenir créateur de contenu ou pour les
entreprises qui veulent savoir comment
ça fonctionne le marketing n'influence
puis comme commencement c'est là dedans
tout pas encore une fois quand même pour
des gens lucides débutants me desgens
folk alliés qui savait était vraiment un
grand succès en un tour dans les deux
journées en fait on était super content
du tout pilar d'avoir selongey qui comme
un faucon consignes en enfer il faut
continuer à pousser mais le coach des
stands où après si je rentrais à
l'université à chessy et chantereine
prévu parce que je faisais tellement
pour moi même temps qui sévit au site à
l'université temple infectés comme ils
sont au top quand tu arrives tu fais
j'en mets ton tu fais quelque chose que
tu avais en tête place est ok ça marche
tu réalises vraiment parce que ce serait
aller simple le tu dis ok aguesse je
retourne dans l'école pour apprendre des
concepts genre un peu abstrait sur genre
ce que je fais des jeux concrètement
dans la vie le feeling que tu as des
couilles mais la piste est vraiment que
mais justement tu es ma première année
d'université comme hec pilar l'hélico
qui agit fait on line up le premier col
c'était vraiment important est ce parce
que la majorité est encore super musique
est vraiment comme large vraiment pas
temps utile pour ce que j'essaie pour ce
que je fais tout fait ça me fait un peu
perdre à ce propos mais maintenant je me
disais que si je range a fait un
baccalauréat en administration des
affaires à concentration marketing j'ai
pas encore fait un cours d'un premier
thing j'ai pas encore fait un co qui
m'apprenez concrètement de quoi t rex
commence à décourager mais le film je
vais faire quelque chose qui a vraiment
bien marché c'est oui mais c'était plus
décourageant pour moi même temps caen
qui est allé m'asseoir sur les bancs de
nuages a répondu moi j'ai l'impression
que c'est quelqu'un d'assez bas c'est
que le au site il cita soit le nantes
lens 2-3 du monde sont très rigoureux
pas sont sortis avait pas ce qu'ils
sortent à chaque soir dans les 1500
première année
entre un gong crise et n'ont jamais vu
ces accueils dans la vie palpitante
d'abord caché chez cammas et le pion aux
gens mangent a été mon travail comme
prix santé je savais que je devais
acheter mon gameplay comme on dirait
qu'ils s'en foutent piqué que sont
justes gens tout le temps cela pourra y
acheter comme pulgent je n'ai comme
schapi dans ses textes étaient comme des
jets a définitivement jésus m'a forcé à
porter jumaa force dès que je sortais
beaucoup hôpitaux puis maintenant j'ai
vécu plein fouet
pif je te pose une question vraiment
simple et aladine mais quand même
fondamental qu'est ce qu'ils disent que
tim est tombé au total plus vu que toi
tu vas manger bouger 28
le père je suis dit c'est maintenant
deux mois que j'avais ton âge
instagram c'était beau je pense ou prou
à ce que comme je connaissais pas ça pue
tétouan justement secondaire cégeps ça
faisait partie c'était être grande de
ton quotidien de ta vie piste -comme de
tout le monde autour de toi c'est comme
quand même a été agressée mais qui
est-ce qui parce que l'homme et ont
bougé au absolument aucun jugement par
rapport à ses pieds la question est
petit et de rien mais tu aimais tant que
je parle avec mettons d'autres amis deux
mois plus vieux encore qui regardent le
phénomène influenceurs il ya là qui
regarde ce que certains incompréhension
voire découragement de voir ce que ça
envoie la jeunesse le cpie je veux dire
je passe pas ce mais qu'est-ce qui
étudie maintenant kika qui achetaient
fait secondaire début cégep
le jeu vous les graines des moments mon
truc mais c'est quoi qui motive les ce
désir le degré d un côté sa g soit en
mai et plusieurs choses l'homme et on
s'assied aux au début c'est en fait un
des facteurs qui m'avait fait historique
et puis qui m'avait fait réaliser un peu
de l'espoir que j'avais là dedans je
sais pas moi une fille ce qui fait qu'on
a des manques à moi je commençais sur
instagram c'était le moment où est ce
qu'il y avait des rovers puis alex et
suresnes qui était comme raymond yu jeu
puis j'avais entendu que je peux c'est
comme un entrepôt de quoi me expliqué
comme la réalité pour un mode de vie
tout récemment il voyage est tout le
temps là il était l'un des plus beaux
endroits du monde et tout public
expliquait que dans le fond il voyager
gratuitement où il se faisait une
veillée pour voyager à cause des
partenariats puis à cause de voir
réseaux sociaux puis une fois j'avais
j'ai comme en temps de s'acheter wildgen
il réussit vraiment fort ce 6e c'est le
moment qu'ils continuent montbrison
commencez à vous plus j'en avais une
communauté tout fait je me dis ok
peut-être que si j'en étais je
m'investis plus et tout peut-être qu'un
jour ça va ma réalité m'ont fait mal au
cul je me souviens juste à être plus que
sérieuse à bord dit gentiment jusqu'à
d'enfance que je le fait vous parle par
le plaisir ou s'il parce que si
j'aimerais ça serait vraiment d'ici le
départ c'est élise ce serait aussi le
montage et une schizophrénie aujourd'hui
comme largement déconnecté de ce que tu
fais pitié c'est de faire ça tu emploies
ouais si cet effectif dirais que c'est
que quand j'avais comme commencé sur un
stage d comme wagon peut-être ce happy
to put finalement tout ça m'a amené a
justement commencé sur youtube commence
à faire des vidéos qui maintenant comme
c'est ce que j'aime j'adore force c'est
du tout c'est vraiment la plateforme
préférée maintenant c'est vraiment par
le que je peux avoir un contact direct
avec mcnaughton de vrais petits plus
profond où six pompiers
si ces deux là j'ai développé vraiment
ma passion pour comme le prendre des
vidéos plus comme tirées du tout
graphique faire faire du montage aussi
j'adore sauf si fou parce que c'est ce
que les réseaux sociaux m'a fait
découvrir le sait avant d'être là dedans
puis c'était beau temps l'aspect
technique à la ria de photomontages puis
de cp ce1 que que juste le fait de
mettre la solde du montant dû comme pour
moi c'est si le sentiment qu'elle j'ai
quand je termine une vidéo puis fier du
résultat est tellement incomparable
comme toutes les prisons comme
souffrances pendant le montage des hôtes
et je pense je sais en ce moment
ça fait déjà comme une semaine que je
travaille sur mon blog de la guadeloupe
que j'essaie de sortir cette semaine
si comme le développe qu'il entrait me
prend le plus de temps à faire le pas ce
que dit vraiment long j'avais vraiment
beaucoup de deux vidéos et tout c'est
sûr que si sûr que n'importe quoi même
système sommes en été si longtemps je
venais ci s'améliore mais non je
commence à voir la lumière au bout du
tunnel approche de la fin et puis
comment est ce vraiment une bonne vidéo
puis comme ça ça me rend tellement fière
et puis content que tout le pied après
sa fin quand je suis comme je m'assois
que je regarde la vidéo prendre dans la
foi avant de l'exporter planète reach
cas des fois aussi gens que j'ai mis
quelque chose dans un certain nombre
whaou
vous ne voulez pas ce que c'est si l'on
est il fou mais tu es pauvre et et
montage soit moi sacoche démontage se
démarque vraiment je trouve c'est
vraiment bien mais sera bien fait de la
musique bien choisie tout et tout est
nickel
je pense que tu as fait du coup le
toujours bon d'être un mois d'octobre a
notamment fait 23 vidéos 1 en 23 jours
ouais ouais ouais ben j'ai seulement mon
fils l'enfant une fois en trois courses
tout ne s'est pas jamais comme prévu
j'ai fini parfois responsabilité une
vidéo 1 au total mais
pour moi mais comme j'ai tellement
occupés à force ça m'a fait vraiment
essayer quelque chose de nouveau qui ont
un style de vidéos et de montage comme
vraiment différent de ce que je fais à
l'habitude c'est pour moi un blog voyage
ça veut prendre un peu près 30 heures de
montage du mieux outillés des fois plus
d'une fois - métro lui de la guadeloupe
en ce moment ça me prend pas non plus je
sais pas combien de temps je compte pas
mais ils ont raté
mais si c'est fabuleux pour le bloc tout
petit je me dis ok si je ferai le
fardeau je peux passer trente ans sur
une vidéo de ça il faut que j'analyse à
mon enquête je travaille depuis la maman
que je prends la vidéo puis comment
qu'elle joue le foie puis c'est que
jerry organise depuis que finalement si
c'est grâce à trouver des moyens
différents
c'est incroyable ce que tu arrives à fin
si le titre il dit c'est seulement ce
qui est le plus fascinante à regarder
des vidéos
tu as toi tu instagram twin flame style
proche de lester chose d'autre chose que
tu mets ton temps à 21 ans fait un bel
hommage qu'on travaille sa nouvelle
série avec et moi si huawei livré
websérie crowdfunding étant linda waite
exactement longtemps campagne de ce sous
financement
et puis ça pourra vont être subventionné
subventions du gouvernement d'enfants
ils se sont associés à nous mais pour
obtenir la grosse subvention
gouvernementale faut qu'on atteigne
notre objectif dans la société campagne
de sophie de sauvegarde le dos large
exactement puis l'on est rendu à une
pure +4 10% je crois il nous reste comme
30 jours fondu
faut travailler fort on avait déjà les
bourses une web série sur la
spiritualité sur le yoga s'appelle
voyage puis nounours travail cette
websérie ces parfaites j'avais expliqué
pourquoi moi je me suis je fais partie
ce projet c'est que j'aime vraiment très
loin de là et puis claudine qui la
propriétaire de douchapt yoga qui est
une compagnie qui organise des retraites
de yoga et tout ça m'a évité à venir à
sa retraite
ah ben ali qui était comme au mois de
septembre ou 70 puis moi je suis allé là
bas puis c'est là que j'ai appris c'est
beaucoup on a fait du yoga chaque jour
la médiation chaque jour puis on nous
apprenait plein de trucs puis ça m'a
vraiment comme voir à ce monde le puits
depuis ce temps là j'ai commencé à
intégrer les pratiques quotidiennes dans
ma vie qui me font sentir tellement
mieux dans la vie tous les jours c'est
vraiment des petits changements dans la
vie que c'est vraiment facile à
appliquer que n'importe qui pourrait
former les gens ils savent juste pas que
tu peux commencer par l'oti genre on
dirait que moi avant je me disais comme
je sais que c'est bon pour ton cerveau
ce faire la méditation c'est bon pour
toi mais je le faisais pas passé me
faisait peur parce que je sais comme on
dit ici tellement d'ici l'été c'est
juste de commencer un petit 5 minutes
mexico les changements concrets te fais
tu dans ta ville et au volant de cette
nation qu concrètement ondrais les
pratiques moi j'applique le plus
quotidiennement sic et maintenant je me
réveille plus tôt je me réveille entre
6,6 et demi puis la première chose que
je vais faire le matin à la place de
checker mon téléphone comme j'ai
toujours eu l'habitude de faire ça
vaille de m'élever faire directement ma
méditation pendant dix minutes après
c'est le salut par des jours chauds
chaque jour je vais aussi avec comment
je me sens mais ça va de prendre le
temps d'écrire d'écrire un peu comme
c'est souvent moi si j'avais su que je
me réveillais pis si avec toutes les
choses que j'ai en même temps je me
réveillais paix comme l'ex travaux je
comprends ce film peut savoir tellement
de choses à foix triet a dû retourner si
t'es pas cap' fois que je me sens quand
je prends je prends le temps de
m'asseoir que j'écris dans le monde sont
appliqués mak et le sang demain je me
sens comme ça cause de cyprès finalement
j'arrive à délier
kim instruisent pourquoi puis qu'est-ce
que je peux faire exactement je me sens
mieux je me sens plus léger tout
pratique de même qu'elle ait commencé à
intégrer que j'ai appris au travail tous
ceux qui nous ôtera voir la websérie
c'est ce but c'est de montrer que des
petits trucs comme ce que tu peux faire
ce que tu peux appliquer la vie qui vont
faire des gros changements qui au
travail s'ils doivent cei on va aussi
aller comme voir pleins d'autres
cultures dans le monde d'autres manières
de penser d'autres modes de vie pour
comme s'inspirer de bus qui les
ramenaient puis d'essayer dé au bout la
ligne aider les jeunes à être moins
stressé puis anxieux à l'idée du
documentaire which way puis tout au rôle
dans ton titre maintenant dans cette
aventure c'est quoi moi je suis la
réalisatrice qui souhaitent des bobos
mais c'est référence à ce que tu as dit
teddy le les quantités levée tu as
tellement à faire que tu te lever
stressé cela c'est ça résonne tellement
parce que j'ai le moins d'avantagés
crans à faire plus d'affaires que j'en
faisais avant qui sait ce que c'est en
fait je me réveille jusqu'à des affaires
puis je sais pas trop quoi puis séoul
si je ce sentiment là qu'un pressent
qu'il faut que tu fasses de quoi
maintenant seules 5,6 urgent mais tu
sais pas par où commencer
j'ai même pas pourquoi c'est sûr je me
disais c'est juste parce qu'il faut que
tu le fasses culpabiliser mais ouais
mais le stress est vraiment ces cas
c'est une sorte de flou justement contre
le permis sur papier encore août le pot
de pas vraiment fait acquis les
priorités c'est ce soit pour des jeux
faso le caecum juste une espèce de tubes
de boules le genre de truc à faire oui
et puis des fois je m'acquitte prend pas
le temps de transport réfléchir à ckoi
sophal des flamands de viti finit par un
peut rien faire parce que de prioriser
qu'est-ce qu'il peut y avoir un risque
moins important
ou finalement au lieu d comme tardé à la
chose qui te reste tu fais les familles
dénis multiples lamente écoutez j'ai pas
les reprise d'osi de tennis fit part ne
pas pratiquer ces examens mais ouais
c'est même moi j'ai vraiment quand même
depuis ma session d'été comme la crise
le comme ça cette année puis récemment
j'ai vraiment commencé à me développer
des techniques pour justement éviter de
me réveiller le matin avec ses boules de
factures c'est maintenant avec ma
nouvelle routine matinale et tout ça me
permet de ne plus me sentir comme ça
puis aussi c'est quelque chose que je
faisais vraiment pas avant que
maintenant je fais c'est à chaque
journée là chaque début j'en retire
comme tchéquie qu'est ce que j'ai à
faire une foire un jeu d'horreur de dans
quelle période de temps je vais faire
quoi
parce qu'ils étaient vu que je travaille
à la maison mais comme je fais quand
même plein d'affaires différente s'il
faut que je sache comment organiser mon
temps je joue pas dans un bureau à
chaque fois dans un bureau différent à
chaque fois qu une toge différentes
affaires non si c'est fatigant même
titre que je peux facilement gens dits
board et puis quand même finalement pas
citer la journée fort danger aussi je
crois qu'à tes jetons m'inquiéter
diversifie ses passeports sur une chaise
puis les dames et ça c'est le fun que ça
va bien plus finalement dix mille feux
la tension là dedans mais les
responsables savent bien à charge petit
c'est vraiment dur de jongler avec tout
ça en même temps qu'à travers autonome
de donner de l'attention et gala tout
dans une bonne proportion est
définitivement ça c'est vraiment le bon
plus gros challenge de gestionnaires de
données comme autant attention ou comme
autant d'attention que le projet
nécessaire
c'est en ce moment que même si je suis
encore étudiant à l'université et tout
comme si je dirais pas que jacques
jagger d'autant à mes études qui est à
mon travail parce que pour moi en tant
que mon système français qui y prévaut
objectifs mais que je pense pas qu'il te
montrerai comment dire ça maintenant
c'est que tu as de la pohdh à chaque
note
martin freeman à 6h30 je fais je me dit
pendant dix minutes après ce fait de la
pauvre c'est comme ça nous sommes des
mutations non mais sérieux c'est que là
maintenant j'ai mes examens finaux qui
arrive dans deux semaines
majoritairement fait le co cc jusque
dans semaines avant puis deux millions
tu peux le coran soit pour cette semaine
aussi je suis toutefois d'un coup les
cours à distance est ce que ça fait là
oui j'avais un cours à l'université st
jean industries de la musique puis il y
avait un examen à mi session
un exemple la fin de la session tu
travailles deux semaines pour ce coup le
nom mais je travaillais deux jours la
veille de l'examen j'arrive à
bibliothèque le matin je pensais tout
les modules puisse aimer ton genre des
modules qui étaient comme des questions
priest les flamands tout est question
dans l'exemple avec les gens mais quand
j'étais moi durée avant publication
georges de 8h à minuit ce soir au hockey
ou tu penses même pour décorer même pas
dans mon esprit la veille clarita claque
mais modules et voilà mais qui met avait
si les travaux nat et j'en ai des
évaluations deux habitations deux
exemplaires pour hacker facilement que
ça marche et que j'ai juste et j'ai un
gros examen final du synode est censé
comme si ce seuil est pas de la une
pendant session le design c'est juste à
la fin en même temps que l examen final
faut que tu ailles remis trois travaux
noté ou jean trois évaluations notées
des fois ça dans certains cours
maintenant le chemin qu qui était comme
commenge en partie à une entreprise ça
c'est que je dois remettre jean 15
travaux n'a douté un par semaine fait
que le ch comme je suis non mais
sa facture je sais juste comme
franchissement savons toutefois dans le
coupé allemand à date je m'en servais et
des marettes que des fois c'est pas la
méthode des recommandés ou habituel
métier ça fonctionne vachement sèchement
6 jeux parce que je travaille bien
supprimée sentais la pression d'aucune
j'apparais journée commence très tôt et
c'est moi ta journée où est ce que tu
fais à qui atteint leur jeu sur la
plogue puis le jeu relaxe pour l' la
souris ou non non ah ouais ouais je
pense que c'est quelque chose que je
devrais commencer à faire plus souvent
ma date annoncée se tient maintenant je
conduisais pour venir ici qu'elle est en
train de me dire qu'il faut quelqu'un
multi conduire je vais revenir à la part
que je conçois pas de montage que le jeu
est facile non
c'est pour moi s'arrête jamais vraiment
un élément les seuls moments que je
dirais que c'est vraiment comme une
plogue ces séquences shame honte chat ou
avec des amis ou la famille ou de cash
avec d'autres personnes
mais si moi je pense une sororité seule
chine ou six ans que je travaille sur la
souris non j'ai pas fai orange a pas
écoutés netflix j'écoute pénurie parce
que sinon j'ai l'impression que camille
je prends mon temps alors que d'autres
sur la sphère andré mais c'est justement
parce qu'il ya tellement tout le temps
des choses à faire surtout avec comme ce
que je fais bien avec les réseaux puis
tout de suite tu peux toujours en faire
plus de toit des limites jean failler
il faut soit mettre une limite sinon
maintenant on vire fou ouais bien
d'autres pas moins non mais c 'est mais
j'ai bien dit on est tous des niveaux de
tolérance aussi à quel point on peut
travailler tout au moins au niveau de
tolérance à ce point mais c'est aussi
parce que j'aime vraiment ce que je fais
je pense que l'esquissé mettant juste
aujourd'hui je fais j'ai fait du montage
de la journée la moins riche comme je
checke là je vois qu'il rendu deux
heures que si je me mettais à 6h à 8h le
matin jusqu'à au moins jeudi 12h je me
suis même pas levé j'ai même pas favori
je vais évidemment concentré j'ai
tellement dedans mais en fait c'est le
temps de penser comme celle g je
travaille de plus en plus avec les primo
dernière main pour plein de projets puis
lui si un gars qui a un milliard de
province et mills à la basse et lance un
million d'abord puis lui c'est vraiment
tout ce projet je suis jeune j'ai une
équipe qui équipe le négligez pas
définitivement mais tellement en demande
comme que son oral est à leur prêter à
la journée longue avec le déplacement et
plus et si c'est vraiment ces foules
puis il aux jo on était ensemble ils me
dirigeais gens viennent acheter ce qui
était qui se trouve à être pas le doigt
parce que je sais pas si l'annoncé ou
aller vers le mieux comme acheter un
pain groupe lexsi grecque puis machine
un gamin
comment tu fais rajoute un autre
affirmait on dirait que juste avec les
projets que j'ai avec toi ça mais tour
10 - l'éthique lundi
timan et 10 me concentre sur ce que moi
je capable de faire puis tout ce que moi
j'ai pas capable de faire ou que moi
j'ai vu déléguer méthode je m'en occupe
même pu y a pas un moment de ma pensée
qui se pensent à ce n'est pas un moment
de la journée où est ce que je pense à
ça c'est fait maintenant dans ces
festivals au beach club de tout ce qui
est la finance va tomber j'étais curieux
de tout et je peux pas mettre de
l'énergie a pensé à ceux
enfin je peux rien faire pour ce même si
je pense le plus peut rien faire peau
fait que je pense pour que ça libère
tout ton esprit tout à ta place mental
pour tout le reste de trucs que tu peux
contrôler ce que tu peux faire
maintenant c'est sûr que quand on a une
équipe s'arrête c'est sûr sûr sûr mais
ma tension si on place de façon plus
petit dans nos vies à nous toute la
charge mentale qui est occupée pour des
affaires que tu contrôles pas au final
ces foules mais ton juste de penser à
jean mélo mais j'attends j'attends le
retour d'un meeting dans les terres mais
pendant que tu y penses de repos ce
samedi leur poule t'as pas besoin de
penser aux trucs que tu peux pas faire
toi même
à ce moment là que c'est un truc qui a
donné que moi je trouve très intéressant
le nombre de fautes pareil j'ai envoyé
des emails ou déjà des messages sur
facebook j'ai besoin d'une réponse de
gens qui portent elles datent d'un an
j'ai besoin de réponses
puis le genre attend la réponse puis
t'es pas capable de passer à autre chose
parce que tu veux régler aussi élevé
c'est la pire des anglais c'est parce
que j'en attends pas rageant pour
répondre aux demandes sur com courriel
c'est tout simplement parce que si je
passe du temps à maintenant à répondre à
mes textos 10ème toute la patente
schiavone je veux juste que je tombe la
charge actes et des fois je me sens mal
pour tous ces enfants qui je le sais
qu'il attend la réponse
match com sinon je ne peux pas gâcher
donne parce que ça rentre tout le temps
tu es sarrail peugeot c'est comme
l'équipe fait un blessé très bon tout le
monde apprécie referme ce qu'on sait
exactement ce qu'il faut faire parce que
ça m'a choqué c'est ça mais moi je
devrais pas sur moi je devrais faire
plus mais j'ai j'ai un coach pour garde
d'avoir des notifications 1 mais les
messages message il répond
automatiquement mais c'est que ça ça me
crée un stress au quotidien parce que
parce que quand mon cell
at on jamais ça je peux répondre je vais
quand même pas leur mettre dans ma poche
le tir dans ce qu'est ce que j'aimerais
faire justice eux le soir ça me
prendrait peut-être 20 minutes répond à
toutes mes courriels team et on max
alors que sinon je fais ça je suis juste
penser à ce gamin qui n'ont fait
interrompre ou sinon tous quoi c'est
selon des fois je me demande jusqu'où
les gens ils foncent dessus juste pensé
dans la journée c'est surtout quand vous
vous attendriez seniors la conversation
cruche capable samedi 7 xtreme passe au
témoin moi j'envoie des messages vocaux
ah ouais c'est 3e au point la tabbee s
camani falloir que je les aimais tant le
montant
c'est à moi que cette passion que tu
aimes vraiment s'y met on t'aime et on
leur soumet criticité fait ces vidéos
mais il ya une chose ou quelqu un pic en
faisant montage parce que c'est
tellement peur de travail n'étaient pas
précis des enquêtes mais pas non plus
dans des business innovants mais s'ils
souhaitent c'est quelque chose que j'ai
déjà pensé itoule comme si j'ai déjà
travaillé avec une amie tout on le fait
de gens de vision semble année de rang
et tout mais on dirait que où ça que
j'en suis où simon montage est tellement
comme si tellement moins pu tellement ma
personnalité psicom je peux je pense que
chelsea city avec mon team de mots tout
ceci
puis j'ai l'impression que si je le
donne à quelqu'un d'autre et qui savent
peut être autant moi mais
ses claquettes et je vois comme plein de
gens qui sont plus big sur les réseaux
et tous et ont vraiment leur équipe avec
fake c'est aussi c'est quelque chose que
j'aimerais avoir la décence qui est ici
ce que j'aimerais savoir thé avoir avoir
mon effigie travail pit ou mais je pense
que je me verrais délégué de montage au
complet à quelqu'un mais quelque chose
que je pense de plus en plus faire c'est
mettons pour le groove le voyage c'est
d'eux que quelqu un poste qu'il fasse
les premiers jours off que je pense mais
c'est la première fois que je passe
outre avoir tout le foot il joue comme
si des fois ça peut être ultra longs pis
ça prend peu de personnel et vous passez
pas le montage final four le ménage
là-dedans non et c'est facile on préfère
c'est pas beau ça moi je fais le après
il dit tout ça ça me manquait une grosse
partie de la job des jeux mais
sinon tu es un haut niveau pour comme
délayé tous genres est avec avec sin
pour comme björk aux âges qui pourrit si
on pense que je faisais j'ai vu notre
vidéo que ce celle puis-je savoir au
départ que c'était comme ça y est c'est
bon c'est bon
non mais on se dit qu'est ce que ça la
deux ouais non mais je trouve ça triste
parce qu'il pourra maintenant les gens
qui en achètent puis qui l'emportent et
que tu es sûr que tu ferais bien navigué
avec sedan en vie dans la classe les
gens y vont chez qui on est ce que ça
veut dire pour toi tout petit et que je
ressens intéressant en même temps que ce
soit un petit jean claude narcy jeune
star depuis que ça fasse réfléchir les
gens attendent aussi jeune revenus ce
qui est avec go croche pied en france et
on pense vraiment vont au bureau 2020 au
bureau mois on aimerait cinématiques sur
notre bureau mais aussi comme un cuir ce
pays respecte et ça sera aussi ouvert à
m on a beaucoup d'amis qui sont communs
qui sont et photographe vidéographe puis
tout ce petit monde laïc ma maison comme
peu de d'endroits genre vous travaillez
tous facteurs devrait bien voir comme un
espoir qu'elles ont et gens peuvent
venir un bureau si ça serait juste comme
un endroit pôle créatif et tout ou
presque on pourrait aussi jean minjoz le
compagnie puis le on pourrait
potentiellement des légumes si c'est
faux je reçois des candidatures de
stagiaires genre à chaque semaine
puisqu'une dont sollicité à pau fait
ailleurs et ce sera comme le déclare
voyez moi pauvre cc1 sollicitations des
fils et filles du monde gens des petites
secondes de la france qui sont comme un
stage à mourir dans son entreprise
commune alors on vient de commencer
tandis qu'il ya des gens qui seraient
intéressés afin qu'ils nous c'est sûr
que ça nous avait rien de vraiment
inquiétant peuvent avoir deux stagiaires
ou des riez à d'autres gens si on ne
peut oublier
un rendez compte
parce que leur vol le viol qui comprend
rien ok boom un besoin travail explique
est temps que toi
finalement ça commence et que vous
donner des conférences sur un peu donner
des conseils aux gens sur comment
journal les réseaux sociaux exactement
puis le 6 et puis là on était simon
étaient les deux comme faut l'occuper
avec l'uni et toupie leur promenade et à
des questions mais qu'est ce qui se
passe avec includes que ge a répondu
québec sans ça on était super occupée
mais que ça reste un projet qu'on veut
continuer à bild doute mais qu'en ce
moment n'avait pas le temps plus ça
donne que alexandra puis cours d'ubs et
vu ce solide et cette journée le puits
est l enfant elle est vraiment un groupe
background en marketing organisation
d'événements est tout à fait plus
vieille aussi le comme 28 et ses vieux
sa faible puissance à pied puis elle
avait déjà remarqué à montréal on
n'avait aucun événement à plus grande
échelle sur le marketing des fluence
puis le marketing digital et tout comme
tim et y en ait des événements comme ça
ailleurs le monde mais on ne peut pas au
québec fecq et paquets le site elle
avait vu qu'on avait revient du premier
inn prime spécifique avec un peu comme
suivi puis le directement quand j'ai
fait ce prix là il fera courir puis en
me disent chez j'aurai moi je fais si ce
jeu clairement intéressé à vous aider en
ce projet dans ce projet de lettre
travailler avec vous là depuis toujours
se faire inviter une zone de rencontre
sur un coma qui tu sais pourquoi pas
mettez vous en avant que le coureur est
tellement différent penser à ce départ
c'est jean inaperçue jusqu'à comme
sombrer dans l'oubli puis finalement
manqué que j'en suis quand même pas une
nostalgie elle a vu c'était comme si
vous aviez m'écrivent terrain clairement
il y avait comme quelque chose de
particulier tout réglé finalement si on
s'est rencontrés puis comme directement
sur nos visions on dirait que
cliquez pas vraiment la même vision de
wes qu'on voulait amener in france
puis avec l'expérience que alex on
savait qu'elles allaient pour vraiment
année nous aider à amener une option si
tu donnes ex-rivaux parce que c'est ce
témoin piscine que mon échec nous nos
expériences sépariez de travail puis
tout se met comme alex aviez vraiment
nous compléter au niveau organisation
puis quand vraiment événementielle qui
étaient comme des aspects qu'on avait
pas tant que ça et puis si cette faille
on signale rien dit alors on s'est mis
pour sur le travail organisée où il se
trouve en suisse à bâle du cavalier mais
à sa taille pour organiser le deuxième
in fine ce qui était notre dernière
banquette à notre édition qu'on a fait
tout bonnement à montréal ouais règle
est devenu l'événement de quelques
semaines dont on a fêté la semaine
passée face à cette année que celui à à
montréal ça s'est tellement les portions
maintenant comme si c'était vraiment fou
parce qu'il est on le soldat john rice à
ceux d'olivier jean petit
deux jours avant mais comme la semaine
avant on était comme ma gueule on va
paris sera venteux les billets non c'est
fou parce que dans l'événementiel les
gens achètent beaucoup comme dernière
minute puis un petit sait jamais comment
ça vaut réellement se passer jusqu'à la
journée même avec nous c'était comme
beaucoup de planification beaucoup de
stress et finalement on les 28 et sur
d'autres on sur place s'est super bien
passé tout le monde nous donnait des
commentaires super positif a compté
jonker dekhili gens sont encore
imprécises et ça fait quand même fait
qu'on était on est vraiment content
depuis le 6e la beuze à montréal on
était comme inquiet il faut vous le
ramenez pitou enfin on a décidé de on
avait vu que tu y avait certaines
personnes qui nous demandait de l'anah
québec 20 juillet on était quand même si
on veut répondre à cette demande le qui
ont valu à québec libre est un être qui
pressent québec a été quand même un gros
challenge parce que on est un peu dans
notre hype de comme tous nos événements
sont sourdes à tout va c'est pas bien ah
oui j'ai aussi oublié spécifique on
commence à faire des cinq à six le sont
en effet de prendre 5 à 7 en septembre
qui a été de son dauphin on était
fuglsang aura ça va bien tout va bien un
peu de crème dans le var genre tout ce
qu'on se touche de vienne là c'est pas
la même si tu peux pas te permettre
c'est finalement l'événement s'est bien
passé au bout la victoire mais c'était
quand même plus classe pee maintenant ce
que je retire de cette expérience je
sais que tu peux jamais jamais tu as our
sur ce qu'elle tombe jamais arrêté
tonton grind puis penser que comme tu es
dans une bonne position où est-ce qu'ils
étaient parce que ça peut toujours comme
si ça finit jamais de changer tout
changer d'un jour tout dans ce milieu le
tcs ne peut rien prendre comme prêts qui
tu veux pas penser que c'est parce que
le ça va bien ça valait bien là même où
s'était justement comment tu envisages
l'avenir de mauvaises influences puis du
métier d'influencé en béton parce tu
parce que c'est complètement s'il nous
volonté au terme d'examens métier ce cas
un phénomène nouveau jeu gratuit
quatrepoint circulation qui mettons je
pense que des gens veulent une couple
d'années et puis le gisti je connais
rien mais flins coupe d'années mais dont
les premiers sont arrivés là ça a été la
mine d'or carrément parce que il y avait
vraiment montré déçu puis le de plus en
plus bas le t4 le premier découvrir nov
c'est un des points les poches métier
maintenant qu'un que tout le monde sera
content maintenant qu'il fait exactement
les semaines exactement c'était une
usine avec l'aca qui expansion double de
plus en plus de monde qui qui qui qui
veulent faire ceux qui sont intéressés
par ce est ce que parce que ça va comme
un gros c'est où ça va se transformer ça
vaut dix paquets ce qui se passe avec ce
que j'étais en train de faire des
chèques en kiff
mais maman qui si je pense pas que le
marché va être saturé un jour de vérité
dans ce sens qu'il ya toujours de la
place pour tout le monde est toujours la
place pour de nouveaux contenus pimd
nouveau type de personne intelligente en
veulent toujours plus ce qui est que les
gens ne font pas j'ai écouté une
personne qui feront une personne en
force au pays mais l'a ensuite par
rapport à à la fois qu'il a justement au
décret kaka mène du nouveau bassin des
français à chaque année c'est que oui le
cnca mon l'essor de des lions comme rina
bonne et tout mais
tarif pour la majorité c'est que est-ce
qu'il ya réellement sucre il dit on
aussi à monsieur prendre des photos est
ce qui attise se sont pas rendus le en
travaillant pour se rendre en faisant
s'est passé mais face à levon sera
lancée avec la plateforme
le yogi bear head qui vous dit bonne que
cela dérange pas d'être assise avec
occupation de béton ils vont s'associer
avec eux aussi factice en mieux et tout
mais souvent c'est un franc soleil qui
sort do dès maintenant et mon pote
perdurer dans le temps parce que le rêve
de haut d'hier et descend chaque année
quand qu'il la nouvelle saison revient
puis aussi parce que quand je suis
revenu au plus beau mais là tu as dit
l'exemple parfait de quelqu'un que su
prendre l'opportunité puits construit
quelque chose de très spécial et c'est
là que je revenais c'est que si
maintenant le taux d'isf égale au chili
la forme de quatre ressortir d'aude et
non celui de la plateforme ans bien 6 7
6 face à veux juste partir aussi
rapidement qui a sévi puis après comme
un an puis personnes vous serez appelés
toi tu es mais si tu réellement
l'intérêt pour la création contenu puis
c'est un peu entre eux d'une communauté
sur réussi à apprendre du pigeon tes
envies en faire plus mais si tu veux tu
veux pour perdre et puis ça va vraiment
donner un travail puis ça veut vraiment
que ça peut avoir des effets à long
terme aussi mettons dans nos
entrepreneurs à petit c'est comment
l'utiliser pour comme par rapport à ton
entreprise et tout ça peut être comme
foule vite scellé tout mais juste c'est
le futur de les futurs et août et dans
tout seul moi j'ai l'impression que
bientôt puisque en train de se faire les
entreprises réalisent l'impact réel que
tu peux avoir sur les réseaux sociaux
puis que ce ça va pas aller en diminuant
tellement bon port tournée vers les
médias traditionnels pour faire leur
marketing et que j'ai l'impression que
plus de monde qui vont aller vers ceux
plus voir des budgets vers ceux plus à
vous soucier de tier 1 mettant m j'avais
justement pour reprendre l'exemple de
lier les primes en effet seuls six
essais ce qui fait dans sa vie
et puis on a fait une pub ensemble pour
nos pleurs dans le fond quitter ou au
costco puis on a montré nos statistiques
après qu'on a fait parce qu'on a su
prison très simple avec nos propres
plateformes fait qu'on ne pas payer
d'influencé ont un serrement aussi pour
payer nos autres métiers c'était notre
plateforme puis avec les stades ce qu'on
avait suite à cette campagne là on avait
mis 500 pièces là-dessus 550 postes puis
violée regardez ci dessus combien savent
comment ça vaut peu comme sa tv pour
atteindre seul ces personnes savent au
15 mai
c'est fait que les compagnies vont
réaliser sur moi j'ai l'impression si
des compagnies aériennes à l'infini
cette écoute la radio tantin trois
minutes de pub à chaque doublette
effective d'une agression tout le monde
va transférer vers semaine je vois pas
vraiment de six lits à ceux des
publicités vous veut passer tout le
temps à travers les gens travaillent les
personnes mettant les personnalités
d'influencé par le marketing web
j'imagine mais c'est ça c'est que le
marketing digital marketing les flux en
ce sens n'a fait que grossir puis comme
les stats le monde aussi requis que
justement à chaque année les compagnies
coupe de plus en plus leur budget qui
étaient investis dans les médias
traditionnels pour libre pour l'investir
à la place dans la stratégie web pierre
avec elle le marketing des fluence parce
que ça rapporte bien plus qui justement
comme comme site explique josé pour 500
pièces tatin le même nombre de personnes
qui avec 15 mai sera doté en examen
j'essaye de penser comment je comprends
même peu commun que les compagnons ont
pu mettre tellement de cachan tellement
longtemps dans des pubs à la télé mais
ton ou comme dans des billboard
et puis tout ce que je me dis comment ça
pourrait être rentable mathon comparé à
aller retour investi les terres entamer
maintenant se maintenant quand tu
réalises qu'une façon de l'inde encore
charisme en plus c'est sûr que des gens
qui vont qui vont soumettre millionnaire
peut-être que marc fues y en a plus
vraiment
s'il y en aurait plus de temps seule
méthode
à ce moment le seul en fitness le fait
que personne d'autre que lui qui avait
se croire de les affecter les compagnies
de financer celui qui s'était c'était
lui le billboard chez les compagnies de
fitness maintenant mettons qu'on veut
maintenant que manger une compagnie de
thé que je veux je veux vous expliquer
le monde qui parle
non mais tout le monde qui parle de
m'accompagner ce soit des défis qui sont
dans la dans le yoga mais tant il fait
des choix en tabarnak le tri effectué
peu comme plus distribués sur toutes
leurs plateformes à place d'avoir une
personne oui mais un ace que j'allais
dire dans tous mes jeux
mais quand j'ai commencé sur les
résoudre et j'écrivais juste en anglais
puis moi je me disais ailleurs comme le
truc qui me fait plus chier dans ma vie
publique comme testé sur les réseaux
maintenant c'est le fait d'un québécois
je voyais sait vraiment comment une
désavantage me disait ailleurs comme le
marché tellement petit qui c'est comme
si ce n'est jamais pour avoir un devenir
you tuerie réseau à cause de cet outil
au début je trouvais que c'est vraiment
mauvais et où le finalement je me rends
compte que c'est comme un aimant la plus
belle chose elle veut parce que le fait
que les marchés québécois sont ensevelis
permettant des mois passent vraiment mon
marché justement les gens qui me suivent
ils avancent les seyssois des québécois
canadiens ou des français était fait que
le camp qu'il ya des compagnies mettons
je sais pas coca cola qui est seulement
qu'ils veulent faire une campagne en
amérique du nord ils vont prendre et ils
vont séparer a qui vont faire une
campagne états unis une campagne canada
anglais une campagne québec fait que au
québec son nip autant que l'on vit
tellement mieux de ce au québec des gens
mais ton avec 2 millions d'abonnés l'a
élu que puis-je genre parce que
justement quand tu es quand tu parle en
anglais sur les réseaux dans un monde où
ce moment-là 2 millions en rythme
exactement tiens il ya en plus alors que
au québec et c'est justement il ya comme
deux personnes qui ont peu stimulant la
bonite syllabes est plus marqué chez moi
et c'est sur pied après ça c'est comme
tout le monde et genre comme un jour des
paliers
un certain point québec mais ce qui est
quand même avantageux pour nous parce
qu'il restait du compagnon peu je
travaillais avec le petit bassin goni au
québec - pour atteindre cette audience m
mais mets toi mais ton bleu est ce que
le paysage a changé de ton bleu trois
ans versus aujourd'hui avec jeux tomates
dont parlait de la vague daudet est ce
que tu peux chargé la même pitch charger
ou de charges plus hautes charges égale
à deux chiffres le maintien 1 parce que
ces genres de ce genre de métier de rêve
en guinée
vu de l'extérieur l'accession qui va
avoir plus d'appelés peu d'élus le tri
vote du monde qui voudraient influence
opiacés que ça lève un pou pauvrement
aux moyens il y en a plein aussi le type
ou du monde qui va réussir a aussi créé
quelque chose
débuter une communauté ils vont en avoir
plein le si vous êtes un petit bassin
mais est-ce que vous allez rester un
petit bassin tellement balancer chez soi
il va toujours avoir du nouveau monde tu
arrives il surtout à cause et rodez mais
en dehors de ce les à la grille les agri
sur les réseaux sociaux de youtube et
instagram surtout instagram arrête pas
de changer puis arrêt peu de
désavantager les créateurs de fac
maintenant d'essayer en 2019 si vous
percer sur instagram
c'est vraiment un gros trafic phase 2
quad vraiment spécial jamais vu pour
converser sur m 6 tyrone mais il ya des
nouvelles plateformes comme secteur que
tu peux percer comme seule fac les
soumettons ça peut vraiment être naïf
pour gens du monde tu veux commencer
itoule puis quand tu es juste ma maison
je sais de qui pouvait prendre au 6 mai
dans les plateformes comme surtout un
style en maintenant ses rangs des gens
un peu ses effectifs pour les gens qui
est qu'ils veulent mais quitte moi je
pensais vraiment et je suis du tout pitt
techtoc que tu peux que tu peux mais qui
joue des capitouls parce que sinon c'est
avec les algues à l'audience c'est
vraiment pu comme cet aval et puis ça
elle peut de changes équivalent 8,8 et
instagram jeudi à vannes est aussi mec
est un contour est ce que est ce que ta
g joue un rôle d'intermédiaire là dedans
au bout du tout petit face aux autres
mettons l'argent qui se fait rare c'est
agréable mais il ne touche rien comme
quand même comment il y avait foule
argent les pauses points sur 58 ont
tellement publicité pour six ans si toi
tu pays une fois un poste sponsoring
instagram va savoir quel genre de
personne wheeling à mettre de l'argent
sur la plateforme fed à partir de là ils
veulent monter stats va se mettre à
montrer de moins en moins des
publications étaient abonnés fin 8 votre
homme a pris en moins de gens qui voient
mes pauses gens mais ça tu as pas de
baisser que j'ai payé plus d'argent pour
que plus les gens de jean niveau avec
les deux vraiment c'est dans un cercle
vicieux qu'il soit payé plus que le
hentai encore plus le web soit à ce
point là c'est ce qu'ils font le succès
se rabat belge revient dans le milieu
pour les investisseurs constat hockey
parce que c'est toujours les articles
toujours de la recherche j'essaie
toujours de comme les vins peu pour voir
qu'est ce que c'est quoi les avancements
la plate forme qu'est ce qui va se
passer aussi parce qu'il s'est quand
même c'est important de s'assurer que
d'autres s'accrochent de moins je veux
le savons c'est certain que les autres
c'est sikimic le ces trucs le ilga ce
que je pense pas qu'une personne de koné
mettait fin qui fait qu'il ya des gens
qui ont regardé les équipes qui ont
remarqué cet art danse le matin
ouais souvent si qu'elle émettrait des
études de cas qui sont faites vous si la
vérité ils vont mettre on prendre
plusieurs préfectures ont testé
maintenant même chose que les compagnies
qui se dédie à essayer de figurer les
algorithmes sont les réseaux oui moi
parce qu'ici c'est hugo nécessaire parce
que tu sais exactement c'est quoi la
recette du succès mais tous veulent
appliquer exactement france va être
capable de foi qui paraît que
c'est une question de recettes et à
l'heure où est ce qu on prendre le temps
this it et il n'est pas seul résultat de
protéines mais tu en vois beaucoup de
temps beaucoup de titres lechanga
parlais tantôt quand je disais donc
entre quant au fait des photos de
voyages son premier voyage c'est comme
ce qui plaît à ce moment là mais ça tu
le vois passer c'était voile et trend
constamment le pilote ça ça se termine
un petit peu mais le trend comme
l'authenticité overworld ou est ce que
tu te montres des pires moments ça a été
ça pas en en tête le dernier six mois
leur transfert vers quelque chose
d'autre que je sait pas encore c'est
quoi
non mais c'est insultant ça change tout
le temps de figure c'est court et
surtout sur install c'est comme ça peut
tuer qui trouve mai
non c'est vrai qu'il ya définitivement
c'est parce que tu es là tu n justement
l'authenticité pitou que oui c'est une
chaîne mais en même temps quand y penser
c'est pas logique dans son ski avant qui
dans les années 2000 même avant c'était
l'atelier ses limites du traditionnel 2d
parfaitement léché tout est parfaitement
exécuté
le retour de comme 2008 on commence à
voir les réseaux sociaux oh my god
je peux rejoindre des gens qui me
ressemblent l'oeil ajouté au fait que
commença peuple
si monsieur madame tout le monde qui
fait des vidéos de chez soi fa clair
c'est que tout soit on est crainte pour
la première fois de ta vie tu vois
quelqu'un qui te ressemblent sur l'écran
tu vois quelque chose de dirigeants
c'est pour ça que les grilles sociaux
ont exposé à ce moment l'est parce que
les gens pouvaient enfin comme vilain
comme apprenti chez ces jeunes de voir
aucune image par seulement l'échec était
dans les médias qu'ils apprécient ce kit
avec youtube c'est que sa grossesse
grossier pu amener mettez les gens ils
se mettent à fait justement les équipes
de production
c'est le contenu sans lui de plus en
plus léché tout est parfait la clé est
signée à avoir une job de 3,6 sur
youtube qui comme au tour de jean 2015
c'est les vidéos parfaitement léché
parfaitement travail est activée tu vois
que tu oublies big jo youtube
l'américain puis tout ça c'était comme
si chez que la vidéo tout est parti
quand place et tout le monde a compris
par les plans est tellement beau
exactement
klaus et c'est ce qui est arrivé dans
les dernières années c'est que les gens
se sont à nouveau aux écuries de ceux
qui étaient comme qu'est ce qui s'est
passé avec le hot youtube règlement
intérieur bring back hand youtube le
sait que les gens voulaient juste
rebours du vrai puis rebours de tandis
que c'est celle que tu vois des
créateurs comme par exemple les matches
à berlin
vous serez skins ont acquis ce sit in
ils tomberaient américaine que blow dans
les com et ondule dans les années puis
elle une raison que tu es la raison qui
avait le blues le blues venge en six
mois répond à ces deux comme 0 à genre 3
millions d'abonnés supplémentaires en
dix ans dix maisons quelque chose comme
ça mais c'est pas rapidement parce que
dans l'océan des young boys américaine
mettons son enfant je sais que tu es
juste à tout le monde qu'ils fassent du
contenu gens fouillent les déchets
générés les généralistes allemand sa
mort le 6 mai qui avait des exceptions
qui tout au plus pour une
il est arrivé avec ses vidéos qui était
comme faugeras encore le ciel avec un
des buts ont les cheveux de cracher
tousser puis quand apparaît comme un
camouflet sans censure est peut être
moins qu'un mois ou gentil hollande en
plein boulot comme sauter c'est fou
quand même temps je me dis pour elle que
blow up qui en six mois à la 10 millions
d'abonnés
combien canon qui font la même affaire
avec des boutons les chutes croche qui
ont 125 view survie des hommes beaucoup
sans doute énormément
tout à fait je comprends pas qu'elle
quand même des fois pourquoi certains
d'affaires explose comme ce petit c'est
une question parce que c'est ça a été
présenté aux membres de youtube et des
sticks et oui des fois je me demande
comment c'est comme quelqu'un qui joue
là bas je vais afficher cette vidéo à 5
millions de personnes meurent aux
abonnés c'est logique c'est vraiment la
plateforme qui décide de mon couple -
youtube qui décide qui quitte le web
complètement ses freins cette angoisse
tu t'apprêtes à un contrôle de ma
tondeuse est à la merci de ses plates
formes dans le fond mais poteau qui met
les règles moi et c'est fou parce que
comme ça c'est quelque chose que je me
dis je me détache de ce match c'est
quelqu'un de la tchèquie tout béton
c'est quand je publie une vidéo tessella
m'attendra qui suivent les jours qui
suivent m'étais je vais chez qui le
nombre de commandes entre chaque veau
que comme un kaka sport c'est tout pis
le à chaque fois qu'il m'attend je vois
qu'il ya performent moins bling
d'habitude puis samatan youtube et elle
m d'en face s'aperçoit bien avec les
youyous studio ça dit pour justifier un
mois l'état grâce à sa mère
ta vidéo performer 50% pour une vie
qu'elle est petite et intel 2,8 et comme
shit man plus gentil ça se paie c'est de
comprendre mais comme c'était pas trop
facture maintenant je sais juste de com
me détacher le thé dansant ce qui est du
moment que moi j'ai terminé ma vidéo que
je suis fier d'une oie de je l'aimais le
puisque si j'essaie de juste regarder
qui les commentaires postés
l'interaction avec les gens mais thil de
peu matt hardy au nombre parce que on
dirait que j'ai pas de contrôle là
dessus de ce que j le contrôle de six 6
mois le contenu que je mets pitt et de
l'interaction je vais avoir des
personnes qui ont vu le contenu puisque
c'est au bowling c'est ce qui est
important je pensais c'est comme pour
garder ce contact avec ma communauté
médicale pas toujours essayé de gérer ça
pas toujours parfaitement bien performé
puis le comité des fans barrière en d2
et pas laisser atteindre par la
performance parce que parce que aussi
amman et il faut s'écouter parler
contenu qu'on a envie de faire pour vous
un petit béton j'ai regardé la vidéo la
plus vue cet agenda une vidéo
dès que tu lises histoire sexuelle fois
qu'il dort je l'écouté et ses droits
d'arnac n'était peut-être pas à vis de
juste part des vidéos qui par les
accusés n'ont sans doute pas des trucs
que tu es le groupe a annoncé sa pièce
c'est quelque chose si quelqu'un met
tait pendant un certain moment cette
année je me tais retrouvera comme
acheter comme [ __ ] satisfaite de mon
contenu que je matais m'attends
d'ailleurs je comprenais pas pourquoi
pire en échangeant hakim est ce parce
que j'écoute une puisque j en ferai ce
que je pense qu'ils vont marcher faut
que je fasse il faut que la précieuse
comme je fais une vidéo puis communiants
savio le chéquier battant nice 2-1 mais
comme je la mets parce que je pense que
les gens vont l'aimer téva que ces gens
moi je me sentais [ __ ] mais là d'un
puissant physique à l'école ni les plots
non plus jeudi à safi séance par est
dans ton travail exactement enfin glisse
tcsa juste de prendre un stade bac puis
de froch qu'est-ce que moi j'aime
réellement faire comme vidéo juste que
ca depuis aussi de jeu mais je m'étais
rendu compte que mal et c'est beau quand
même influencé par jean luc et les
autres faisait jean mathon c'est comme
tout mais apporte oui tant sur les
raisons des mauvais goût le monde mange
de la bouffe
as rome malades vite faisait influencer
par des influences mêlées on doit
maintenant j'essaye de comme j'ai mis un
time limit sont mes réseaux sociaux pour
ne pas consommer trop de réseaux sociaux
et juste juste - publié me concerne les
gens de mac comme communauté mes
interactions un procès car qu'est-ce qui
porte tout je peux rester debout 10h lun
qui se fait plus trop automatique
noailles conférence là dessus exactement
infecté un peu mais sans trop tomber
pendant que désormais juste secours
massage et un match et qui joue enfin
que c'est que tu n'as pas c'est une
autre affaire celle des gens qu'est ce
que j'ai perçu est juste de prendre des
images de vraiment que tu ne sais même
pas si j'essaie de couper un peu dans le
temps des craintes de voir fin de
journée ouais mais il me dit à chaque sa
manie comme attentant voici ses mots si
c'est par jour mais 10 en moyenne par
jour
mêlant jeu multi par jour parce que je
sais que souvent c'est roule le nombre
d'armes par jour c'est trop et première
m je me rappelle c'est mémé plateforme
en fait ma plateforme instagram arrêté
de grossir qu'un quand j'ai arrêté de au
stockage poste allé d'un commentaire
il répond à toutes les commentaires ou
créer des conversations plus que
l'algorithme il ya plus d'action ce
retour c'est fake mais fait que même à
croissance a arrêté arrêté de répondre -
bâti quand j'ai arrêté de guéret sur ce
bouton de chéquier comme en première
heure ça fonctionne bien sûr faire lol
mais ma qualité de vie est tellement
deux gestes forts qui n'empêche mais
cela puisqu'il guillopé on s'en fout non
mais c'est vrai ça tu ajoutes tellement
dans le mental puis surtout comme tu es
pour nous qu'ils ont de dire oui dow
jones on bosse on est idiot de justement
comme j'ai une communauté gérer les
interactions pitou puis non c'est moi
avec qui on doit arrêter de mettre le
nom justement sur le fait de comme
répondre à des commandes et surtout sur
instagram peut pas que j'aime moins ma
communauté instagram je les aime son
super métier on dirait que je préfère
mathon prendre le temps de jeu peut
aller des dilemmes qui sont comme plus
j'ai pas mal ont piqué leur personnalité
leurs factures 11h je trouve ça plus
important de mettre mon énergie là d'un
ça m'ennuie je peux juste qu'un peu tout
faire en même temps
mais non c'est ça justement ce mandat
comme dispose de quoi que ce qu'est ce
qui se passe puis tous ont baissé c'est
fou parce que c'est fait dans la manière
qui a les réseaux sociaux sont fait ses
premiers livres pour être addictif gens
m'ont été faites en fonction que ce soit
dictée pour quelques petits veille avant
les feedbacks doivent aller voter
malgré tout ce qu'on essaie d'effacer ce
mauvais c'est ce pauvre est est ce que
ça t'a enlevé un petit peu de de
pression et je viens tu déconnecté mon
écouteurs sans tuer
oui qu'est survenu senti moins de
pression d'avoir des statistiques
maintenant des business un jean des
statistiques instagram et on paye ou
double cd ça c'est que tu peux utiliser
pour te vends pour des compagnies qui
devraient collaborer avec toi que de le
dire est ce de quoi manger
j'ai ma compagne maintenant ce que je
veux parler c'est pas d'une compagnie de
l'ange à quelqu'un d'autre il
m'accompagne là j'avoue même titre que
ça c'est vraiment tout le monde s'aide
par lesquelles j'évolue en ce moment
c'est dans ce sens que mes compagnes
sont pas encore rendus assez huge pour
que je puisse y est complètement coupé
mon mm partenariat que jean juste
dames et les compagnies tepa
premièrement les deux cd street qui
vient tout juste d'être créé et tout
mais c'est soit que c'est vraiment se le
dise où puis je sais qu'en 2020 j'ai de
plus en plus on aller par le mais c'est
sûr que tu veux pas les stats de ça ça
reste quelque chose d'important sens
quand même pour pousser mais compagnie
si je prétendais matin fait que bye bye
les réseaux sociaux puis jean marie
penser sébastien micropénis on lit les
études à ce puits ou si c'est juste
parce que moi je trouve ça bien moins
l'orgie vraiment du fond ce sera postée
sur youtube a fallu vider aurait filmé
les vidéos qui tout fait ce que je me
vois pas arrêter de sitôt et où le tu
t'envoles un voyage sac à dos j'ai vu
trois mois de ce parti non je vois pas
trop ce que tu fais pas du jardin
dessous mais le je partirai avec ma mère
et mon frère on pas en back pack qui on
va faire la turquie jordanie et egypte
donc c'est paul et c'est pas la création
de contenu qui motive le voyage jusqu'en
fin d'année écrit genre ça c'est
vraiment un voyage de famille puisque m
je suis assez sûr j'en profite pour
prendre photos vidéos et tout mais c'est
pas un voyage de quatre convois puis on
dirait que justement cette année comme
presque toutes mes voyages étaient liés
au travail avec des compagnies ou la
création de conduite où le foot est
comme tu es oui ces gens moi moi j'avais
moi ça me porte pas quand même décrit du
conte en voyage la messe et souvent même
temps avec les personnes avec qui je
suis
si j'en ai des amis qui sont dans le
milieu qui a pris ce peut réellement se
creed qu'ont eus avec sa vie fesci
maintenant on est dans un monde à
meteonews 27 ça me fait chier avec
l'habillage des signes c'est pas si le
fun même s'ils gèrent les photos sur
bahebeck simon chiasson voyage sont tout
le temps même sa de la bamboo
les voyages mais non mais c'est vrai que
cette fois les voyages de 2010 et la
mise en examen qui est maintenant il
faut sonder contre un qui était comme il
serait envoyé un endroit par là par la
compagnie ou élèvent leurs petits puis
de mettre leurs airs de jean six ans la
malaria comme beatles cours d'activités
à l'endroit mais c'est des activités
gens qui te rejoins trop pop y sont
commises à du monde de jean 50 ans je
peux faire mais ça c'est juste pas
didactique et la personne n'apprécie pas
c'est comme se trame en une semaine a
frappé à la fois que tu veux pas parler
sa main fait que je pourrais chanter les
voyages les ouvrages d'influencé c'est
pas tout le temps comme tu vois survie
réseau on a exactement
mais si ça marche je suis vraiment
excité parce qu'il savait vraiment
voyage d'exploration et d'aventuré c'est
vraiment cool puis juste après comme
dans son jeu peu religieux continuer
avec ici n'ont fait un voyage avec f
vous ai parlé de la france et sa
compagne accueil de gabory pilon on veut
faire soit une ou deux pieds destination
le ca qui dubai et écuries du sud faites
le si tout va bien on fait les deux
géants du smi sinon on va faire une des
2 1 1 2 après si je mangerais bien
montréal 1 en marchant vers un bon
feeling savard lie pour le lieu pour moi
de série sam à blanc oui si tout va vite
ses hôtes il va bien aller qu'est ce
qu'on peut souhaiter car la famille
c'est quoi de mieux pour toi c'est quoi
de mai mais pour moi mais ces errements
d'euros vous avez dit si vous avez un
bureau c'est ouais c'est ça mais je
pense que c'est quand même le 5 c'est
comme ça c'est spécial parce qu'à chaque
fois que tu es comme dans un moment
comme ça dans la vie on dirait que c'est
quelque chose je pense constamment tgcc
beaucoup de villes visuels de ça c'est
un autre truc un peu pratique et j'ai
commencé des messages laissant que ça
après je tiens on dirait que la vie mais
plein de comm xingu genre d'opportunité
pour preuve le moins affecté mathon j'en
avais même pas comme ces ragots que moi
puissions n'avait pas en avait parlé à
qu'un peu personne d'autre
kloet et j'ai un ami qui comme à
échanger tout juste d comme eux
d'aménager à mon nouveau bureau on est
de l'espace puis tout genre comme traite
dans tout comme jean ils savaient même
pas qu'on a cherché à tout prix dans
l'univers bonus et c'est exactement ça
que non ce serait ça c'est le même
bourde j'irai mais sinon vraiment de
focus et surtout les trucs que je
travaille des jeux je cherche pas
m'embarquer dans des nouveaux gros
projets d'envergure mama world book is
also kg
me stimule et je suis vraiment emballé
par ce projet factice je peux même être
la moins quelque chose qui comme en 2d
qui se dit que ce qui pourrait être le
temps des soldes je fais mes gosses a
toujours été de faire une collection de
vêtements avec une marque gens établis
je veux maintenant que avec björk rush
gentiment fait vraiment plus de la main
en train de développer nous nos produits
tout se fasse mais savait dès maintenant
avec est tous égaux les gens long terme
d'israël en mettant dans ma vie je fasse
en 2030
oui j'aime ce que me laisser surprendre
qui cotisent their genre je pense à ma
vie dans la dernière année dernière 2 1
dans les deux ans et depuis j'ai comme
vraiment genre créer moi-même mon chemin
mettons pas ce qu'il était avant tout
aux cgpi commun proposé tandis que je
suive au planning de vie normale puis là
maintenant que je termine moi même mon
propre rejoindre ici je me dis ah yoye
est tellement choses se sont passées un
peu de thym comme je m'en moque skis
tout ce que tu fais en plus c'est
tellement on sait pas où ça sans vous
tous ceux qui l'attendent on ne pas
aborder le sujet met à parler de tik tok
qui comme une plateforme qui s'avoue
j'abrité koala sa part 0 puis puis
laisser sa pile tout je m'agite que le
t'utilises pitt mais une partie de ta
création
je commence à mettre plus d'efforts
c'est justement parce que en ce moment
il ya une opportunité à saisir le pic
est morte c'est vraiment foule aussi tu
peux mettre une vie des gens tu peux
avons zéro abonnés mettre une vidéo la
vidéo va aller vers eux comme ce qui va
vous rejoins 500 personnes il faudra que
montevideo puis vabre au comme cinquante
mille personnes qui font ça bientôt
profil de même c'est vraiment easy est
ce que c'est parce que ça fait penser
ben moi d'alger publié jean 5
et ou de paix il y en a une là-dedans
qu'italien peu varmatin.com 350
c'est comme si la première vidéo ce que
j'ai bossé sont explique robbie
mais s'ils avaient pillé comme certaines
scènes est vraiment bonne là dans la lah
l'analyste paquin pouvoir c'est quoi qui
fait c'est quoi les facteurs vont faire
bloquer une vidéo puis agrandi des
points l'un des facteurs qui n'ont pas
de bateau parquet qui qu'il ferait aubry
feraient ils veulent cela il faut
soutenir les compagnies sont très
maigres budgets sortie edit c'est fou
pitié à protecteur qui va renouveler la
fois qu'une nouvelle affaire il faut
constamment tueur et akron tomber si les
nouvelles règles nouveau médium mais je
sais pas quel point c'était un sens il
ya toujours des gens qui essaient de
développer des nouvelles applications
des nouveaux réseaux sociaux mais c'est
difficile pour faire migrer légende
plateforme d'enfance qui comme des gens
comme le monde il intègre facebook
maintenant c'est passé comme il l'a
facebook si j'enlève le ballet jaune en
coin dizaine d'étapes mais c'est que le
cirad ce mets ton club le 10 a cédé shit
facebook
c'était des chips et puis le maintenons
nos parents c'est là dessus que l'on
fait qu'à la fin mai 4 août dans
paramètres techniques il faut la
retrouver ou ouais mais je pense que
chaque réseau comme une utilisation à
plus de différents jeux next par un
sniper allons aussi hilare a eu lieu
dimanche en une mamie chinoise que je me
suis abonné est incroyable et tellement
drôle et le col 60 ans puis a fait des
techniques incroyables
j'en sais c'est vraiment un curé fille
comme des petits bijoux une cadence pic
à chantepie est tellement qu au fait que
c'est fou c'est vraiment pour tout le
monde sait que le temps est comme
plateforme eb66 comme je disais sur
chaque crise où je trouve comme son
utilité différents gentil zwei arrêtons
facebook pour que contacter encore tête
et exigeant
monde est heureux que le maintien de ces
photos du tout plus les vidéothèques ces
gens les gens font ils
ils font juste qu'un acte créatif qui a
faim depuis c'est ça qui est vraiment
des choses pour ce qui est déjà malade
mais bref tout point d'éclair de ça va
être quoi ta vie dans cinq dix ans hakim
attention s'ils me posent la question
même moi moi c'est sûr que d'ici l'heure
à l'autre de mes gros objectif c'est de
machines vente la rénover de vivre dans
ma vente mois exactement janvier un peu
vécu en australie un prêt au portugal
puis comme depuis joncy c'est vraiment
quelque chose que je veux faire si je
peux juste arrivé de la vente de
prestige ou revivre le process de gens
dans la vie tout fait que je me verrais
bien disent le faire ce métier genre en
ce moment je pense que j'ai quand même
dix engagements qui me force à peu à
rester imperméable ne pas parler trop
longtemps maintenant fait que je serais
passé se tue des gens n'ont pas
longtemps on a laissé en pensant à
farine 26 tout fait mais sinon ça aux
wsop qui se déplacent pas très mais
sinon c'est sanaa dans plus long terme
gentec bâtiment et j'avoue des enfants
petite fille je trouve qu'il est
incorrect et qu'elle tarde mai
je vais juste continuer à comme
développer des projets qui me passionne
réellement théo moment dans dans cette
année l'été je me dis que ce qui me
passionne en ce moment peut-être trop
faible que dans vingt cinq ans mais je
peux que me forcer à continuer à
travailler sur des trucs que j'aime
potes du bus juste que je continue à
vivre comme je le fais en ce moment qui
est de gaulle de flou mais quand même on
est une discipline bien besoin
un certain planning puis de m'écouter
d'écouter ce que j'ai vraiment une femme
le voyage semble être quelque chose qui
motive qui a été lui aussi le point de
départ de tout sans doute me disait la
question était posée qu'est ce qui te
fait c'était comme mobility voyage
gratis le voyage payé depuis par le vent
bref je te souhaite de continuer de
voyager ça ne dit on pas cette
passion-là ouais ouais j essayais y
voyager énormément étoiles puis ces
séances spéciales parce que le la
journée que mon père est décédé comme on
part vraiment voyager aux quatre coins
du monde puis lui avait une destination
qui révèle ali mais qui jamais pu parler
qui le stralis puis la journée de son
décès qui était à l'automne bleu 12 ans
j'ai reçu un courriel que l'est est la
confirmation que j'allais partir pour le
stage en australie des produits c'était
fou pour moi c'était vraiment claqué six
points
j'allais là-bas pis ce voyage de steam
puis quand ils ferment les lieux dans le
monde sait que jal en grande rio puis ça
a été que puis c'est pour moi pour moi
de voyager c'est vraiment je sais même
pas comment l'expliquer en moule mais
gens grandissent tellement puis je pense
que c'est ce qui fait en sorte que je
suis comme mathieu pour c'est vraiment
un voyage en piteuse les expériences que
tu vis en voyage en deux comme tel
laisser guider vivent des expériences
qui est jamais puis imaginez vie
tu as vraiment c'est dans des endroits
qui sait même pas pourquoi celui-ci
comme le thé était seul face à toi même
hop hop je trouve que c'est vraiment là
que tu conduis le plus en tant qu'humain
et puis le puissant dribble percer des
liens forts s'est rapidement avec une
nouvelle personne de moins par tous
ouais mais c'est vraiment des deux
podcasts
ouais merci j'ai fait sans qu'on ne
ferait pas une affaire du genre de
démarche
non c'est fini